Et bonjour à tous.
Bienvenue les amis de Twitch !
On est sur la chaîne de Gauthier_Geospoil et on va se retrouver
pour ce premier épisode
des braises de ce podium.
Alors vous avez dû remarquer,
si vous suivez déjà la chaîne,
que je ne suis pas Gauthier Joss Stone.
Ou alors j'ai vraiment fait
une grosse chirurgie esthétique,
mais ce n'est pas le cas. Moi,
peut être que vous me connaissez
parce qu'on a fait quelques lives
ensemble.
Je m'appelle Zowie
Lou, Guillaume pour les intimes.
Je vais présenter un peu
les gens autour de ma table.
Du coup, parce qu'effectivement,
on est sur la chaîne du côté Ostwald.
Donc on va l'introduire tout de suite,
ce bon vieux Gautier.
Bonjour, bienvenue.
Comment tu vas ?
Ça va ? Ecoute,
merci de me recevoir sur ma chaîne. C'est
deuxième.
Est ce que tu peux te présenter pour
les gens qui viendraient des communautés
de nos autres invités
et qui te connaîtraient pas ? Oui.
Je m'appelle Gauthier, je suis vidéaste,
médiateur scientifique avec une petite,
un petit attrait pour la géologie,
les sciences de l'environnement.
Mais voilà, on est en 2023, il se ferme.
Pas de porte, donc pas de raisons
de ne pas parler d'autre chose aussi
directement. L'accent
pris vis à vis de ce qu'il y a eu.
Le switch.
Ok, il y a des commandes pour aller voir
les réseaux sociaux de tous nos invités.
Je les ai oubliées
parce que je ne sais pas.
Moi, je les connais.
Point d'exclamation
fredo ou point d'exclamation ?
Je peux aussi aller voir son travail.
N'hésitez pas dans le chat
que vous faites en programmation.
Fredo ou Paul,
ça vous met un petit lien vers ces réseaux
et vous pouvez aller voir.
Abonnez vous.
Il fait un travail
sympathique. C'est votre.
Deuxième invité qu'on a autour de la table
Valentine, une sorte de.
Comptoir. Bonjour.
Comment ça va ? Bonjour.
Ça a l'air d'aller, ok.
Écoute.
Est ce que tu peux te présenter du coup ?
Pareil
pour les gens qui te connaîtraient pas
et qui viendraient des. Communautés de.
Nos jours.
Je suis Valentine,
j'ai fait plein de bruits parasites et
je parle aussi de géologie.
C'est aussi mon travail
et ça va sur la chaîne YouTube.
Science de comptoir.
OK, du coup je vais juste de redemander.
La. Commande de Valentin.
Oui, commande Valentine.
Séance de comptoir
ou ton prénom Églantine ?
Voilà. OK, donc un point d'exclamation.
Valentine pour d'exclamation de comptoir
ou pour l'exclamation Églantine.
Vous avez le choix,
vous aurez les réseaux sociaux
de Valentine
si vous voulez aller voir son travail.
Tout pareil que Gauthier.
Troisième invitée Clotilde Sauvage.
Comment ça va ? Ça va ?
Cette seconde a l'air très stressée.
Je me demande ou on va atterrir.
Ça va bien se passer ? Ouais, je pense.
Est ce que tu peux te présenter
pareil pour les gens qui se connaissent ?
Oui. Moi,
je suis vidéaste sur la chaîne PC Sauvage,
qui est une chaîne qui parle
d'archéologie,
d'anthropologie et d'histoire.
Alors c'est la vulgarisation scientifique.
Et j'emmène pas mal de fois
les gens sur le terrain
visiter des fouilles,
des fouilles archéologiques.
Une quartier. Est ce que.
Pendant les formations, Clotilde passait
Sauvage ? Oh.
Mais je ne sais pas ce que c'est ça.
En fait une top.
C'est quoi la commande ?
Oui, tu tapes un point d'exclamation
avec quelque chose et c'est une commande
qui en fait affiche quelque chose
du genre point d'exclamation, passé
sauvage.
Il va avoir une description
de ton personnage que tu vas jouer
et un lien vers la chaîne.
YouTube
et d'un point d'exclamation Gloria.
Et donc le dernière invité, mais pas des
moindres Arnaud, le stupide économique.
Bonsoir, comment ça va ?
Mais très bien. Très bien
prêt à prêt pour l'aventure.
Est ce que tu peux te présenter du coup ?
Pareil
que Arnaud de ce type d'économique ?
C'est
une chaîne de journalisme économique.
On parle de sujets parfois un peu lourds,
faut le dire, on l'a.
Vu un moment.
C'est pas forcément beau
tout le temps maman, mais bon, des fois,
on essaye de le faire avec
un petit peu de légèreté, pas toujours.
C'est pas une promesse.
Et et du coup
ma stupide économique.
Donc j'imagine pareil avec un petit point
d'exclamation avant ce speed économique.
Arnaud ou Pierre-Alain,
voilà Pierre-Alain.
Tout attaché ou attiré.
Comme vous voulez.
Mais qu'est ce que vous voulez ?
Vous verrez bien ce qui va tomber.
Un modo, ça marche vraiment pas.
Il y a des gens
qui vont veiller dans le château
et vous donner les réponses sans problème.
On remercie du coup
le CNC qui finance cette émission
en partie en grande partie et.
Un petit Français.
Qui fait savoir qu'il
a coproduit avec nous et qui nous prête
entre autres, ce magnifique studio
dans lequel on trouve.
Qui est vraiment magnifique.
Il faut le. Dire.
Merci à eux parce que ça aurait été
pas la même concrètement.
Montée de fait.
Alors vous avez pu voir par exemple que
Clotilde, pardon,
n'était pas forcément
super à l'aise avec le sujet.
Il s'avère que
on a des débutants autour de la table
qui n'ont jamais fait de jeux de rôle.
Soyez indulgents, c'est normal.
Ils seront adorables, ils vont apprendre.
C'est pas un problème.
Si jamais il y a des questions
qui reviennent, des incompréhensions,
etc, ça va s'estomper avec le.
Temps et surtout notre professionnalisme
prendra le dessus.
Sur ça, je pense qu'il y a un message
que j'entends par le problème.
Oui masqué
vous dans le château,
vous allez aussi pouvoir jouer avec nous.
On influence via
des sondages et des quizz, donc parfois
vous aurez une petite alerte en haut
qui vous dira s'il y a un sondage
ou il y a un quizz qui est en cours.
Vous verrez dans le château,
vous aurez des questions
ou alors des suggestions
de Qu'est ce que vous voulez
que nos aventuriers fassent
ou simplement vous répondez ?
Et voilà. Dans le cas d'un sondage,
le choix qui aura remporté se passera
un peu plus tard dans l'aventure.
Dans le cas d'un quiz,
si la majorité répond la bonne question,
vous aurez le droit
d'imposer un bonus ou un malus à nos héros
sur la prochaine action.
Si jamais vous vous trompez tous ensemble,
tant pis.
Vous n'aurez pas le droit d'influer
sur le monde.
Voilà voilà, à la fin de l'émission,
on va se réserver un petit 30 minutes
pour revenir un peu sur les 100.
Tous les aspects scientifiques
qu'on aurait pu aborder pendant,
pendant les 2 h 30 d'aventure,
pas au préalable.
Le but, ça va être de débloquer
les bêtises qui auraient été d'y
revenir sur des sujets qui tiennent à cœur
à certaines personnes
ou qui ont été un peu trop élagué.
Ce n'est pas le mot que je voulais dire.
Mais c'est bien.
On était vu un peu trop rapidement.
Voilà, vous avez compris ce que je voulais
dire.
Et la sage.
Vous pouvez réagir.
Dans le chapitre, il y a les modérateurs
qui vont nous faire passer
tous les messages.
Ce sera avec grand plaisir
et à la fin de l'émission,
on ouvrira les choses comme ça.
On pourra répondre à vos questions
directement
ou alors vous pouvez directement les poser
sur Twitter avec le hashtag
R ou f.
S pour love science.
Ou hashtag relevé de ce que vous voulez
en TT.
Y a pas de souci.
Voilà comme ça
on pourra venir vous voir plus facilement.
Peut être sur Tweeter
que si jamais il y a trop de gens
qui parlent dans le château.
Ça allait être compliqué
de choper vos questions à la fin.
Voilà, voilà.
Moi, côté, est ce que vous voulez revenir
sur un petit point
avant qu'on lance
ou on peut y aller ? Moi, je suis prêt.
Alonso faut démarrer l'aventure.
Un Oscar.
Il y a du boulot.
Générique.
Notre histoire se déroule
dans la province d'Horizon,
une ville très récente qui a été créée
en tant que ville pilote pour
un nouveau fonctionnement institutionnel
pour pouvoir atteindre rapidement
ses objectifs.
La ville reçoit de très
grandes subventions de la part de l'Etat,
ce qui lui permet de se développer
extrêmement vite
en sautant de nombreuses étapes.
On pourrait décrire Horizon
comme une utopie.
Les différentes rues sont très bien
entretenues
avec de nombreux espaces verts disséminés
aux quatre coins de la ville.
Les véhicules motorisés
ne sont pas autorisés,
à l'exception des transports en commun
qui ont été réfléchis
pour desservir très facilement
n'importe quel point de la ville.
Les objectifs principaux d'horizon
sont de réduire les écarts
entre les différentes classes sociales
et optimiser au maximum
les émissions de CO2 de manière
à servir de modèle au développement
de notre ville ou au contraire
de démontrer l'inefficacité
d'un tel modèle de fonctionnement.
C'est dans ce contexte qu'a été créé
le complexe scientifique Elixir,
en périphérie de l'horizon.
Un complexe qui regroupe quasiment toutes
les catégories de sciences existantes
et qui propose de nombreux cours
sur ces dernières.
Son objectif faire avancer la science
et l'éducation au maximum
dans le but de développer encore plus
la ville.
Les accords commerciaux existent
donc entre le complexe et horizon.
En effet, n'importe qui peut déposer
un dossier pour faire des recherches
à élixirs sans pré requis de formation.
Mais le potentiel d'invention
qui en résulte
doivent être proposés à horizon,
en priorité à tarif préférentiel.
Eglantine Bidon,
fameuse start startup
originaire de la région,
a justement développé un nouveau système
qui permet de découvrir
des gisements de pétrole
au sein du complexe.
Elle s'est ensuite
basée sur ses recherches
pour fonder sa start up Flappy.
Néanmoins, une de ses affaires
ne lui a pas été remise lors de son départ
et elle compte bien récupérer ses biens.
Donc Eglantine bidon.
Est ce que tu peux te présenter
pour nos spectateurs
et pour les gens autour de la table ?
Oui. Bonjour, je suis Eglantine Bidan.
Je suis la science
et cofondatrice à moi seul.
C'est à dire ?
Je suis co-fondatrice fondatrice
de Flappy, Flappy et la French.
L'éthologie
a été aussi fort investigation.
Voilà, mon but,
c'est vraiment de mettre au point.
Je ne sais pas à quel point je détaille
en fait ce que tu veux.
Ouais, on est un peu en panique, c'est
un peu délicat, mais disons que, en gros,
on essaye de faire
de la prospection minière en se basant
sur l'intelligence artificielle et
technologie quantique.
Voilà, et donc je suis très
heureuse
d'être incubée au sein du complexe Elixir.
Leur taux d'occupation est terminé.
Du coup, ça fait. D'avoir été incubateur.
De start up, a été créé
et là, tu reviens au complexe
parce que tu dis que tu as oublié
tes affaires. Oui.
C'est faux, mais tu as envie de venir
piquer des trucs en haut.
C'est pour ça que j'ai une valise
très grande et très vide.
Tu es à l'accueil du complexe Adixia ?
Oui, il y a Maryline Alma que tu connais
parce que tu as déjà travaillé
horizon, c'est
l'agence d'accueil et d'accueil du FMI.
Bonjour Églantine. Comment ça va ?
Salut Maryline.
Ça va se faire à toi. Ça va tranquille.
Qu'est
ce que tu fais ? Comment va ton petit
projet ?
Elle va très bien.
Il va très bien en ce moment, il va mieux,
il va remonter la pente, ça va bien.
Je pense fort à lui.
Qu'est ce que je peux faire pour toi ?
Ecoute, j'ai oublié un petit truc,
c'est vraiment idiot,
mais je publie un petit truc.
Tu sais au 14ᵉ et j'aimerais bien
juste passer de récupérer comme ça.
Tu peux m'ouvrir. OK, tu seras.
Le bâtiment est plein
d'étages, c'est un secteur qui se divise.
C'est 14ᵉ secteur,
juste en bas à gauche là.
Et en fait toi, c'est une sous section
du campus quatre, ça fait cinq.
Tutorial te dit
je souhaite que tu me parles.
Dit t'as pas oublié quelque chose ?
Je peux pas lancer un dé.
Ah oui, j'oubliais
juste un bon, un fer à lisser.
Cantique des cantiques.
Ouais ouais, c'est bien ça,
un truc absolument essentiel.
Je comprends pas ce genre de truc.
Je vais regarder ou tété je t'envoie.
C'est normal que tu puisses
pas comprendre.
C'est quand même une technologie assez
avancée, mais si tu pouvais juste me.
Merci.
C'est un peu énervé,
il cherche sur son ordi.
Du coup elle te dit ah ok je vois,
je vois tété
ça doit être stocké en A4 s.
Du coup je peux être dans le quatrième
secteur, je suppose.
Pas d'accord, elle appelle quelqu'un
sur son bipper, un certain Tom qui arrive
juste en agent d'entretien
et qui a du coup le passe partout
et lui demande de t'amener
là bas dans la salle pour qu'il
puisse récupérer tes affaires.
Merci Marilou,
tu es adorable, pas de souci.
Donc tu pars avec Tom.
Tu prends une espèce de petit ascenseur
qui descend au sous sol parce qu'en fait,
il y a un mini métro
qui se balade de secteur en secteur.
Du coup,
tu prends le métro vers le secteur quatre.
Pendant ce temps.
Là, c'est.
Gloria qui pose.
Oui, tu es. Dans le complexe scientifique.
Adixia dans le troisième secteur,
dans une salle.
Est ce que tu peux te présenter
son personnage
pour les spectateurs
et pour les gens autour de la table ?
Oui, alors je suis Miss Gloria, couperose
je. Je suis donc archéologue.
Aujourd'hui
directrice du chantier de fouilles
qui a donc lieu sur un chantier
qui vise à construire une centrale
géo thermique.
Et évidemment, au début du chantier
sont apparus des vestiges.
Et là, moi j'ai dit stop, on arrête tout,
on réfléchit, on s'arrête,
voilà.
Et là, j'en suis là il y a quelque
temps, il y a un peu de temps,
il y a un certain temps de fouilles.
Là qui est nécessaire. Ouais,
du coup,
tu as effectivement trouvé ces vestiges.
Et récemment, sur les premières fouilles,
vous avez réussi à trouver
un espèce de papier qui est très abîmé
mais étrangement bien conservé pour l'âge.
Et justement un complexe scientifique.
Alexia.
Oui pour essayer de voir s'il
n'y a pas moyen de le restaurer.
Donc tu as une petite équipe
de scientifiques
qui est dirigée par Sophie Lambert,
qui est une scientifique qui travaille
du coup dans le secteur trois.
Mais malheureusement,
c'est pas des gens qui ont été formés
à restaurer ce genre de chose.
Du coup, tu vas devoir les lead book,
ce que tu peux nous expliquer
comment on restaure du papier
qui serait abîmé par la pluie
et la terre entre guillemets.
Alors il se trouve que les conditions
climatiques de notre secteur
sont assez favorables.
Il fait très humide là ou nous sommes,
heureusement.
Le papier, c'est comme la peau, ça,
ça fait des rides très vite.
Donc il faut de l'eau, de l'eau,
de l'eau, de l'eau, de la stèle ironique.
Ce genre de chose, quoi.
Donc c'est sûr que là, avec cette équipe,
je l'ai lâche pas, je les drive
comme on dit maintenant.
Ecoutez, nous avons des machines
qui nous permettent de
si vous voulez, de stopper l'aggravation,
la détérioration du papier,
ce qui est perdu et perdu, que
l'archéologie, c'est un deuil permanent.
Par exemple, si on a une feuille de papier
qui serait recouverte de terre,
ce n'est pas possible de.
Recouvre de terre.
Touchée par des traces de boue.
Qui se serait ?
Ah oui, oui.
Incrusté dans le papier, c'est fini.
Ah non, ça, ça, on aime bien la terre
qui recoupe que la terre protège.
D'accord. Oui,
notre plus grand ennemi
pour l'archéologie, c'est l'aire.
Donc l'aire, c'est la poussière.
L'art, c'est la mort.
Et du coup, qu'est ce que ça fait
comme méthode pour ça ?
Je suppose que la terre, ça protège, mais
on peut l'enlever pour voir ce qui rend.
Alors on l'enlève, on l'enlève.
Mais il faut absolument que le papier
reste dans un lieu anaérobie sans air.
Donc là, c'est tout un protocole ou
eh bien on va extraire ce papier.
Nous avons procédé par qu'on
a enlevé la motte,
on a gardé la grange,
je dirais de terre tout autour
et on va l'étudier une fois
qu'il sera dans un espace sans air.
Car encore une fois, l'air, c'est la mort.
Le corps.
Du coup,
ils suivent un peu les instructions.
Donc il y a eu une installation
d'un bloc pour avoir un espace anaérobie ?
Tout à fait.
Et vous avez réussi à enlever la terre
qui avait.
Et vous vous retrouvez avec un papier
qui est néanmoins extrêmement abimé.
Mais peut être qu'il y aura quand même
des informations à en tirer.
Mais le temps,
le temps le dira, je te le fais passer.
Merci.
Vous le voyez aussi chez vous sur le live
pour si jamais
vous le regarder en podcast.
C'est un document, une sorte de parchemin
ou l'encre aurait coulé.
Extrêmement abîmé,
très difficile à déchiffrer.
Traçant tous.
Qu'on voit là.
Du coup,
Sophie Lambert, elle te dit bon,
maintenant qu'on l'a restaurée,
je suppose qu'il va falloir qu'on la,
qu'on le garde.
Ah bah oui, ce serait qu'il
faudrait le mettre dans quoi
comme container pour s'assurer qu'il
ne se dégrade pas à partir de maintenant ?
Eh bien, on va sans doute
le mettre dans un dans un coffret
avec encore une fois
une hygrométrie parfaitement contrôlée.
Pas qu'il y ait de variation,
donc hygrométrie et quantité
d'humidité dans l'air.
Si je ne dis pas de bêtises, donc.
Sophie
Lambert a C'est très très bien faire.
J'ai toute confiance en elle
et ensuite, il
faut surtout qu'on
sache ce que ça signifie.
Le sens de cette
ça apparaît comme une tache pour, pour,
pour tout un chacun.
Mais il y a tout un récit.
Il y a peut être un ancrage mythologique
là dedans
et il faut qu'on trouve
très bien.
Du coup,
elle te dit Ah bah justement, ce genre de
ce genre de coffret,
on en a en salle le stockage à quatre s.
Est ce que c'est possible
que vous alliez en récupérer un ?
Moi, je ne sais pas trop
à quoi ça ressemble.
D'accord, je sais qu'on en a
trouvé ce que tu es
d'accord d'aller en récupéra.
En cas trace. Oui, tout à fait.
J'ai pas grand chose d'autre à faire.
Du coup,
elle te dit Je vous appelle un collègue.
Il va vous accompagner tout.
Elle n'a pas peur.
Du coup, elle appelle un certain Frédéric.
Donc, ça sonne.
Frédéric. Eh oui, allô.
Je te dérange ? Non, écoute, non.
Dis moi, est ce que tu pourrais
accompagner madame ?
Cupro en salle à.
4 à 4, ça n'a pas de sens.
OK, j'arrive, elle est ou là ?
On est en salle 3 à 20 3 h 20.
32 à 30 2 à 4.
C'est OK. J'arrivais
donc t'arrives.
Donc il y a une porte qui s'ouvre.
Et vous vous rencontrez
pour la première fois ?
Bonjour.
Bonjour mon petit Fred, ça va ?
Je suis une vieille dame.
Déjà vu, peut être ?
Oui, oui, je vous ai déjà vu aussi.
Mais ça me rassure que vous vous occupiez
de ce cas là.
Ça me fait plaisir. Je suis là pour ça.
Est ce que tu peux
te présenter pour nos spectateurs
et pour les autres autour de la table ?
Oui, mais moi je suis Frédo.
Frédéric Petit me m'appelait Frédo.
Je suis concierge au complexe Elikia, je.
J'aime la vie, je suis bon vivant,
j'aime, j'aime la viande, j'aime ça.
Voilà.
OK donc vous vous rendez vers la salle
A 404, donc
tu sais que tu es dans le secteur trois.
C'est le secteur juste à côté.
Du coup,
tu dis on ne peut pas prendre le métro.
Ça peut marcher.
Moi, dès qu'on peut marcher,
je préfère parce qu'on va très bien.
Très bien.
Il faut. Il faut rester. Mobile en.
Vous.
Des verres vers le secteur quatre
donc là ou il y a quatre s.
Et en fait, entre chaque secteur,
il y a une sorte de lobby
avec une salle de repos,
des petits distributeurs de snacks etc.
Et du coup les entrées pour le métro
qui sont des espaces d'ascenseur.
Et au moment ou tu arrives dans le lobby
entre le secteur trois,
le secteur quatre, l'ascenseur s'ouvre
et tu croises ton ami homme
avec une femme que tu ne connais pas.
J'étais Offredo et Tom Thomas.
Comment ça va ? Au quoi ça ?
Et comment elle va ?
Marie-Lyne Ça va,
elle va tranquille à côté.
Et qu'est ce que tu fais là ?
Ecoute aux gendarmes,
j'accompagne madame Cross toujours,
qui vient chercher un bac hermétique
pour observer le papier.
Ah ouais, tu. Vois tu.
Quatre. Ans ?
Mais moi aussi,
j'accompagne madame Bidan à.
Chanter Madame.
Bonjour.
Enchanté, bonjour.
Au pire, je ne suis pas très occupée.
Moi, je me suis le.
Gros petit coquin tempéré.
Je sais ce que vous avez
que moi, madame. Bizarre ?
Oui, bien sûr. Allez, c'est parti.
Vous vous rendez tous les trois
vers la salle à quatre s.
Pendant ce temps, devant le complexe
Adixia,
Monsieur Pierre-Alain Chiche fortiche.
Arrive et va rentrer.
Est ce que tu peux
te présenter pour nos spectateurs
et pour les autres autour de la table ?
Eh bien Pierre-Alain, je suis
pas chiche pour aller plus vite.
Si vous avez du mal à dire non
nom de famille, alors
je suis président de Cci et humaniste
donc ça va de soi.
Bon, ma priorité est forcément c'est
le développement économique de la ville,
le tissu économique, les artisans,
les entreprises, tout,
tout ce terreau vivant qui vraiment fait
la communauté de vie, de horizon.
Et donc, j'espère qu'avec mon travail
au quotidien de développer
cette cette magnifique ville,
il va la faire prospérer.
Voilà tout simplement très bien.
Du coup, tu rentres dans le complexe
initial, tu es venu en véhicule.
Est ce que tu as quelques passe droit
en tant que président, en.
Tant que humaniste ? Bien sûr.
Tu. Tu arrives et tu as un rendez vous.
Si tu te rappelles bien de temps.
Background, oui.
Avec quelqu'un,
tu es arrivé 20 minutes en avance.
Comme.
D'habitude.
Mais tu te doutes que vu les circonstances
qui ont mené à ce rendez vous, j'espère
que tu te rappelles.
Je me rappelle, c'est.
Un petit peu étrange.
Tu as peur d'avoir
la moindre minutes de retard ?
T'as envie d'arriver avant l'heure du
rendez vous parce que tu sais pas vraiment
ce qui va se passer et tu te doutes
qu'il va se passer quelque chose.
Ce n'est pas.
Un rendez vous ou normal, ça,
oui, c'est plutôt pas.
Donc tu es devant l'entrée,
donc est ce que tu rentres ?
Et si.
Tu vas, je suis là pour rentrer,
je rentre.
Donc tu as l'hôtesse d'accueil.
Est ce que tu vas l'avoir tout à fait ?
Qu'est qui ?
Oh monsieur, juge sportif,
je ne vous attendez pas.
Alors sourire.
Bonjour Maryline,
comment vous arrive à me très bien ?
Merci.
Qu'est ce que vous faites ici ?
Eh bien, je suis venu pour un rendez vous.
Figurez vous un rendez vous
et elle feuillette un peu Cédric.
Je ne sais pas, on n'a pas prévenu. Alors,
monsieur Petit, il y a ce petit Frédéric.
Frédéric Petit. Rendez vous avec Frédéric.
Pour un rendez vous d'une
plus grande importance, je dois dire.
D'accord.
Du coup, tout le monde a écouté.
On ne m'a pas prévenu. Mais je peux.
Je vous assure.
Je peux peut être l'appeler.
Mais s'il vous plaît,
oui, que ton téléphone sonne.
Allô, wifredo ? Oui.
Dis moi, je t'avais un rendez vous
avec un homme, avec monsieur.
Je suis sportif.
De quoi ?
Chichi, quoi.
Mais c'est aussi sportif, sportif.
On ne t'a pas prévenu non plus ?
Bah non, c'est qui ce monsieur ?
Si c'est le président de la société
d'Horizon, t'as pas entendu parler de.
La cité, c'est quoi ?
Moi, je n'ai pas de rendez vous comme ça.
Ça, je. Peux te le dire.
Il n'y a pas été prévenu non plus.
C'est pourquoi, s'il veut,
parce que c'est un rendez vous
d'ordre business.
Vraiment,
c'est très important et c'est d'ordre
business que tu peux te rendre disponible
bientôt.
Ecoute, oui, là là j'accompagne
et Manu et personne
pour récupérer des affaires.
Oui, après oui, je roule, là, je suis,
je rentre à peine dans le secteur quatre.
Là je vais en quatre.
Ha, ok, bon, au pire, reviens à l'accueil
et tu te rends
ce rendez vous dans la foulée.
Du coup.
Je peux pas, je vais accompagner le début.
Dans la foulée.
Une fois que t'as terminé.
Euh, je dirai atone.
Je comme je dirai tu veux,
tu me remplaces là pour les vitres ?
OK, ça marche.
Ben oui, tout.
Le temps il est occupé,
mais il est en secteur quatre.
Toi, tu vois à peu près
comment ça marche ici
parce que t'as un peu supervisé
la construction de loin quand même.
Pour toi, c'est quand même.
Relativement peu de temps à perdre
parce que j'ai quand même quand.
Tu te dis
d'ici qui finit sa tâche et qu'il arrive,
il sera là dans une trentaine de minutes.
Ça vous convient.
Forcément, non ?
Non, mais je vous
excusez moi, ça, c'était en intérieur,
forcément.
Non, je vous remercie.
Je vais attendre par là bas
et voilà.
Donc je me dirige
vers vers des petits bancs.
Parce que tu dois le retrouver
dans moins de 20.
Minutes,
c'est ça ?
Oui, mais j'ai mon plan à moi.
Je veux ce que.
Tu vas faire des petits. Bancs.
Je vais voir des petits bancs
parce que j'attends que Marie-Lyne
regarde un peu le côté.
Et puis là, d'un air très naturel,
je marche comme si je savais ou j'allais,
mais je sais ou je vais
puisque j'ai construit le complexe. Donc
voilà, et
je marche dans la direction
ou je sais qu'est le secteur.
Quatre.
Tu marches assez vite et. Tu.
Tu vas arriver dans les temps.
C'est assez bien
indiqué au final le complexe.
Le but c'est pas
que ce soit le labyrinthe.
Non mais je.
Sais que je vais porter
les noms des salles sur les salles.
C'est juste après le 3S4S cette fois.
Donc je trouve assez vite
la salle de stockage.
Et donc vous vous arrivez avant
lui même en salle de stockage,
vous entrez tous les trois.
Qu'est ce que vous faites
dans cette salle de stockage ?
C'est une grande salle
avec beaucoup d'étagères, d'armoires.
Il y a vraiment énormément d'outils,
d'appareils qui ne sont pas utilisés
pour l'instant et qui pourraient servir
à plein de blocs dans le complexe.
Qu'est ce que vous cherchez alors ?
Personnellement, je sais pas trop ce que
je cherche, mais des trucs qui valent cher
et du coup, je pars d'un
pas décidé dans la direction opposée à eux
en disant moi
ce que je cherche, c'est par cette étagère
que je pars, je fais quelques rangées
et je me engouffre dans une des rangées
pour essayer de choper des trucs
avec ma pique.
Ouais, mais. Je pense qu'il y a.
Des trucs qui ont l'air d'être plus
que ce que tu peux trouver.
Je prends un microscope,
ça doit valoir un peu cher quand même.
Un bon microscope.
À balayage électronique, ça existe
ou je suis ton petit format comme ça ?
Je te trouve ça nickel.
Tu trouves peut être un petit PC,
un petit Mac.
Un petit Maxwell, mais en format
ça je prends. OK
pour cela.
Il y a pas des bijoux qui traînent
et des bijoux.
Il n'y a pas trop de raison
qu'il y ait des bijoux qui traînent.
Mais qu'est. Ce qui pourrait être.
Pas des petits agitateurs magnétiques là ?
Des trucs, mais dans les bouchons
qui tournent, moi j'adore.
J'en prends quelques. Poignées. Oui.
Tu peux demander tout ça dans un moteur
ou dans mon carnet comme tu préfères.
J'ai pas oublié du tout.
Que ça coûte cher.
Alors moi
j'ai quand même besoin d'un coffret.
Oui mais j'aimerais bien
que Fredo y aille à ma place
parce que c'est très haut et ça me
ça me fait mal au dos
et ça que pendant ce temps là
je repère quelques truelles et j'en
ai bien besoin parce que j'ai moins
d'argent tout le temps sur le chantier,
ça que si je les empreintes,
je l'ai ramènerai même.
Je prends combien ?
On prend
dix, mais c'est quelconque,
quelque casque de chantier.
Voilà. C'est autant ça que du coup.
Oui, oui, oui, j'ai un cabas.
J'ai un peu de place. Là.
C'est vrai.
OK, je. Sais. Vous pouvez m'aider.
Merci.
S'occuper des dizaines.
Mais personne s'en rendra compte.
Pendant ce temps.
Du coup,
on essaie de choper tout un tas demandé.
Et à ce moment là, la porte s'ouvre un peu
avec fracas et Pierre
entre dans la salle.
Donc tu vois trois personnes
dans la salle, deux qui sont en train
de prendre des choses
et lui qui est un peu suspendu.
Vous allez Monsieur Monsieur Petit ?
Oui, Frédéric
Petit. Moi, j'ai un rendez vous avec vous.
C'est vous le sportif, c'est moi.
Chiche !
Vous pouvez m'appeler Chichi.
Qu'est
ce que c'est que cette histoire ? Alors,
est ce
qu'on peut parler un petit peu en privé ?
Peut être sortir dans la pièce d'à côté
assez grande. Voilà.
Donc on va se mettre dans un coin. Là bas.
Ça résonne.
Vous savez.
Oui, on ne va pas vous déranger
peut être ?
Attente de je donne la madame
Madame que je me souviens.
Oui. Monsieur, dites moi
donc je m'éloigne de madame Cupro.
Ce n'est plus possible.
Donc j'entraîne Monsieur
Petit par le bras.
Alors Monsieur Petit, après,
je ne sais pas trop comment l'aborder
parce que là, c'est pas évident.
Comment est ce qu'est ce que je lui
dis, moi, monsieur Petit ?
Est ce que je peux lui dire.
Tu dis ce que tu veux.
Que j'ai vu, ce que j'ai vu ?
Je peux pas. Pourquoi pas.
Après, c'est toi qui voit.
Est ce que Monsieur Petit.
L'affaire que j'ai à vous présenter
me laisse circonspect ?
Moi, je suis concierge, monsieur Petit.
On va y aller assez rapidement parce que
je ne sais pas trop ce que je fais là.
J'ai vu de mes yeux, vu
un esprit ou une chose.
Un fantôme
peut être une émanation paranormale
qui m'a dit de venir
vous retrouver ici à 15 h 48.
Je suis venu ici à 15 h 48.
Maintenant, c'est à vous de vous exprimer.
Et je vous ai fait quoi ?
Est ce que c'était vous
qui avez joué un tour ?
Mais moi jusqu'au concierge,
moi qui je ne suis pas magicien,
qui sous mon esprit, qui vous êtes.
Mais écoutez, moi, je suis circonspect.
C'est quoi ? C'est un métier ça ?
Non, mon métier, c'est
président de la Cci et humaniste.
Ça oui. Par contre, je suis circonspect.
Là, je ne sais pas comment me dégoter
de cette situation.
Comment faire ?
Je n'essaie pas de la mettre en jeu.
Vous me dites que vous avez vu
quelque chose,
un esprit qui vous a dit de venir me voir
à 15 h 48 ?
Il est 48.
Dites moi ce que j'avais à me dire.
Il est 15 h 48 et soudainement,
les lumières deviennent rouge.
J'ai perdu mes notes.
Mais je viens raconter ce qui se passe.
La porte se ferme d'un coup.
Il y a un espèce de bruit de buzzer.
Toi, tu sais ce que c'est, c'est
un confinement d'urgence.
Ça arrive parfois dans le complexe.
C'est quand il y a un problème,
dans une expérience, dans n'importe
quelle salle, toutes les salles.
Se fermer méthodiquement,
le temps d'être sûr, de désinfecter
avant de rouvrir, c'est juste un
code de sécurité.
Les capsules.
Bon, moi je fais.
Je panique un petit peu quand même.
Parce que là, le paranormal, c'est rouge
pour chiche, il n'y a pas de soucis,
ça va se rouvrir, ça arrive.
Soit je ne suis pas rassuré
parce que j'ai peur que ce soit mon vol
qui est déclenché. Ces trucs là.
J'en que
c'est une expérience sûrement,
qui a fait un peu de fumée.
Il n'y a pas de quoi s'inquiéter,
ça arrive souvent.
Ce qui est déjà.
Il un peu blafard me suffit.
Je porte chance, vous allez bien.
Je devriez vous hydrater parce que ça.
Vous fait un peu d'eau.
Peut être. Asseyez vous peut être.
Je vais m'asseoir. Oui, je vous remercie.
Vous avez un tensiomètre.
Mais écoutez,
je pense que je serais au courant
si j'avais la moindre difficulté. Ah
oui, et très bien, je vais m'asseoir.
Effectivement, c'est mieux quand même.
OK, donc tout va bien pour l'instant,
mais d'un coup,
ça commence à avoir un petit problème.
C'est à dire
que les lumières se mettent à clignoter
et une espèce de petite boule
lumineuse apparaît en l'air.
C'est la même, c'est la même que je sais
pas la même que tu sais vraiment pas.
Là, c'est presque la même.
C'est quand même
que j'ai vu la taille d'une ville, Hornby.
Et ça bouge pas, ça flotte en l'air.
C'est tout ce.
Que quelqu'un fait quelque chose.
Est ce que je peux
essayer de la mettre dans ma valise ?
Voilà quelque chose.
Je sais, je vais essayer de la mettre
dans ta balise, éventuellement.
OK, dis moi comment tu t'y prends,
décrit moi la situation.
C'est une petite bille qui vole.
Alors je prends ma valise,
je la porte à bout de bras,
ce qui n'est pas évident
vu qu'il y a déjà dedans.
Puis j'essaye de enfermer la boule dedans
et de refermer.
Et voilà, au.
Moment ou. Églantine fait ça,
vous entendez comme un bruit de tonnerre,
un flash qui vous éblouit
quand Églantine n'est plus là.
Mais la bille est toujours de lumière.
Pour qu'on ne l'ait pas.
Et je suis déjà morte.
La jeune fille, là, elle était,
elle était là.
Elle était et elle est. Vous
vous voyez quelqu'un.
Disparaître sous vos yeux d'un coup ?
Et qu'est ce que j'ai eu ces conneries ?
D'aller chercher ?
J'essaye d'appeler Tom. Là.
Ça répond pas pour moi.
Je vous propose de partir,
mais on ne peut pas partir.
C'est fermé.
Il faut balayer la zone.
Il faut faire un rayon par rayon.
Comme une stratigraphie. A disparu
et quand on l'a vu,
elle était là les fulla
et euh si j'ai pas passé dans le garage.
Si chacun tient son rôle
et que chacun se met la
tête bien, vous êtes bien là
et bien vous allez tout droit.
Vous faites un aller retour.
On se retrouve ici.
Vous, c'est vous, c'est pareil. Moi,
je vais rester.
Là, non, je saurai.
Vous avez vraiment.
Fait ça, ça va, ça va pas bien vous.
Voir tous les deux.
Puis on balaie la zone, on vérifie
qu'elle soit.
Elle est forcément quelque part.
Les esprits, ça n'existe pas.
Les disparitions, ça n'existe pas.
Au petit peuple.
On a Abidal,
c'est Abidal,
c'est
comme quand vous.
Voyez vous deux vous balayer la zone ?
On m'a chercher un peu.
Je suis assis, assis
et je regarde la boule.
Tu regardes,
je suis assez près de la boule.
Je suis à mi distance, c'est à dire
à combien de mes la boule elle fait ça.
Moi, je suis à deux fois ça quoi.
OK, t'es pas si loin ?
Non, je suis pas sûr que j'aimerais
par cette boule un peu plus loin.
Comment cette boule ?
Elle hypnotise un peu ?
Bah oui, je te dis
je comprends pas ce que c'est, c'est.
Un plus en plus. Là aussi,
pas de développement économique là dedans.
C'est assez étrange parce
que malgré le fait
qu'elle soit d'un blanc immaculé, éblouis,
pas du tout, alors que t'as l'impression
qu'une grande lumière en émane.
Mais ça me fait vraiment pas mal aux yeux.
Comme
c'est pas du moi.
Donc tu ne sais pas trop
ce que vous vous cherchez
pour pas de trace de Églantine.
C'est vrai que là on a bon ?
C'est étonnant, mais il y a forcément
une explication rationnelle.
Donc vous dites ça
à coup d'éclair ?
Faites moi un objet de perception.
Chacun, j'ai fait 20 sur 45.
OK on Frédo avoir fait pareil stp.
Et donc moi là j'ai 52 sur
je sais quoi, j'ai deux.
Vous dites quoi ?
Percepteurs, c'est perception
et j'ai 60 52.
Oui c'est bon.
Sur combien. Sur 70 par.
C'est réussi. Du coup, vous deux
vous.
Vous avez eu la chance
d'être tourné dans le bon sens
au moment de ce flash à nouveau.
Mais en fait,
vous avez vu un espèce d'arc électrique
partir de la boule vers Pierre-Alain
et il a disparu.
Ou encore non
mais c'est quoi cette histoire ?
Ce qu'on est pas gagné en finale ?
Si oui, finalement, il a disparu quand
même, bien qu'il était un peu étrange.
Mais attendez madame,
c'est grave quand même.
Ben oui mais.
Bon, je vais essayer d'appeler comme cela,
c'est pas possible.
Tu t'appelles s'est débrouillé comme. Moi,
j'ai mon papier qui se dégrade.
Là, il faut quand même.
Oui, moi votre papier, excusez moi, mais
bon quand même, comme c'est pas possible.
C'est quoi cette ?
Moi je veux voir cette boule là.
C'est bizarre, je te prends,
je la boule, je m'approche de la boule.
Qu'est ce que tu fais ?
Décrit moi et je m'approche comme ça.
Je regarde la boule,
je regarde moi ça ça brille. OK,
je vais voir.
Oui, puis quoi ?
Il dit ça un éclair part de la boule.
Il disparaît.
Moi, je suis, je suis aventurière.
Mais je, ça,
c'est un petit peu toute seule.
Mais GG,
j'ai beaucoup vécu et
c'est une expérience de plus. Je.
Qu'est ce que je dois ?
Qu'est ce que tu fais ?
Ce que je fais ?
Je suis toute seule dans cet entrepôt.
Je pense qu'il faut que je me protège
pour pas que ça m'arrive
d'écrire.
Moi, je pense que tu es brun.
C'est alors vite une idée.
Je pense qu'en fait,
mais mes truelles me protègent.
Je pense que tout ce métal
et mon nom couperose
qui me vient de mon père
Pierre Couperose, forgeron grec spécialisé
dans le cuivre, me portefeuille me guide
et je ne suis pas superstitieuse.
Mais dans ces moments là, c'est vrai que
c'est limite limite.
Donc je
pense que toute cette ruelle en ceinture,
on doivent dévier visiblement ces éclairs.
Parce que sinon, je ne vois pas pourquoi
j'aurais pas été touchée
car je suis quelqu'un de grand.
Mais quand même.
Est ce que tu fais
quelque chose spécifiquement au juste
avec ta ceinture de truelle est. Apparue.
Tout va bien, je me la mets comme ça.
Là, je vais remettre mon chapeau
parce que je pense ça me protéger la tête.
J'ai un peu peur comme des neurones.
Qu'est ce que je peux faire ?
Est ce que je cherche ces gens ?
Ce que bon ?
Le temps passé, je fais un choix cornélien
parce qu'est ce qu'il faut sauver ?
Le récit de l'humanité
ou trois individus ?
Ça, c'est un problème de front.
Pendant cette longue réflexion,
la boule a grossi
et elle commence à lancer des éclairs
partout loin.
Ça pique.
Elle lance t elle.
Lance quoi ? Il y a des.
Espèces d'arcs électriques
qui partent. De corps.
Et qui touchent des endroits de la salle.
Au hasard, il y. Je te dis que.
En mettant.
Des skis.
Oui, il faudrait que je m'en aille.
Je pense que.
Je suis pourtant allé emporter fermé.
Ah oui ? Ah oui, c'est un détail
qui avait la clé.
C'est Frédo, il a disparu.
Et pendant cette réflexion.
Déjà été bloqué dans une pyramide
il y a longtemps.
Je ne sais pas comment j'avais fait.
Pendant cette réflexion.
Un éclair te touche également
qui disparaît à ton tour.
Bon, plus.
Quand votre vision se déforme,
tout votre corps ne vous répond plus.
Des flashes de lumière se font
de plus en plus rapides en premier lieu,
vous ne ressentez rien de négatif,
mais à mesure
que les flashes s'accélèrent,
ce dernier vous assomme et vous commencez
à vous sentir de plus en plus nauséeux
et vous
n'avez aucun moyen de vous sortir de là.
Cette sensation croissante du repos
que ce qu'il semble être une éternité.
Puis les flashs de lumière ralentissent.
Votre vision revient
lentement à la normale
et vous commencez à retrouver
les sensations de vos membres.
Une fois que vous reprenez vos esprits,
vous vous changez.
Vous vous rendez compte que deux personnes
vous ont rejoint dans la salle de stockage
qui est désormais baignée
d'une lumière bleutée.
Et quelque chose cloche.
Là, ça n'a plus rien à voir.
Les étagères et autres armoires
ont laissé place à des machines
aux installations grossières.
Vous êtes assis sur des chaises.
Derrière vous se trouve une sorte de cuve
de laquelle s'échappe une légère fumée.
Ou que vous. Êtes complètement déboussolé.
Que ce que cette histoire là, vous.
Allez, déboussolés.
Tous, me faire un test d'endurance
tout de suite.
Alors.
31 sur 50.
96 sur 45.
Et 74 sur 50.
C'est l'endurance.
C'était dans les premières heures.
Je montre. Au bout. Droite.
Le carré, on va droite.
Ah oui, quinze sur 75.
Donc beaucoup de réussite.
Deux échecs, les deux qui ont raté.
Là vous ne tenez pas le coup
et vous vous mettez à vomir
toutes vos tripes
et vous perdez toutes les deux.
D'un point de vue off.
Donc oui, oui.
Il y a du coup les deux personnes
qui ont l'air de vous avoir rejoint.
Vous vous comprenez pas
ce qui vous arrive ?
On est désolé.
Ils ont l'air complètement paniqué
de ce qui est en train de se passer.
Et vous, êtes qui là ?
Qu'est ce qu'on est ou.
Je dis vraiment ?
Mais non, mais c'est catastrophique, c'est
pas possible. Comment on a pu faire ça ?
Ils disent.
Vous écoutez, on est vraiment désolé,
il y en a un qui est plus âgé que l'autre.
Il dit oui, je me présente,
je m'appelle Gaston,
je vous présente mon apprenti Victor
et c'est catastrophique ce qu'on a fait.
Je ne sais pas comment
on va vous renvoyer chez vous.
Ça, qu'est ce qu'on est au Néoules
ou Gaston ?
Vous êtes dans le complexe
Adixia complet ?
Oui ok.
Et je suppose que vous venez du passé.
Quoi ? Vous pas quoi ?
Vous venez de quelle époque ?
Vos hommes viennent de la salle A 98
dans la salle, quatre.
Dans la salle la quatre S.
D'accord,
mais vous venez de quelle époque.
Du XXIᵉ siècle ?
À l'époque, ça devient de qui ?
On est mardi, on est mardi. Gaston.
Tu me
dis qu'on est mercredi, quelle année ?
C'est l'année du renouveau.
C'est l'année de réinventer élixir
telle qu'on
la connaît
pour pouvoir prospérer dans tout le monde.
C'est pas vous qui dirait le contraire.
Alors là,
je ne suis pas vraiment en état de parler
économique.
Je cherche simplement à comprendre
ce qui nous arrive là.
C'est du passé.
Vous venez de ca.
L'année 2023.
Non ?
Bon. Je ne sais plus.
Du coup, on a presque réussi.
Attendez ici quoi là ?
Vous écoutez, je vous explique.
On voulait ramener, c'était un prototype.
On voulait ramener des objets
du passé de l'année 2023.
On est en 2223 de moins. De quoi ?
Il mine de mon papier. Sauf que.
C'est attendez. Comment va mon fils ?
Ah non, je n'ai pas de fils.
Joséphine
Le problème, c'est qu'on s'était dit
qu'on allait diviser la salle de stockage
en supposant que ça allait
prendre des objets, pas des humains.
Mais il y a des gens
qui vont dans les salles de stockage
pour reprendre les objets que vous êtes.
Vous êtes comme un pauvre,
alors là, on est en face d'un problème.
Ce qui m'intéresse, moi,
c'est les solutions, oui.
Est ce qu'on peut parler solution
un petit peu.
Ecoutez là tout de suite,
on n'a pas de solution, nous,
parce que le concept
de créer le prototype pour
faire avancer les choses dans le temps,
alors ça marche.
Je vais vous expliquer quelque chose
à tout problème.
Il y a une solution.
Je suis complètement d'accord avec vous.
Je dirais même plus
il n'y a pas de problème,
il n'y a que des opportunités.
Mais qu'est ce que vous voulez ?
On est deux pieds dans la boue.
Là, vous êtes complètement
matures. Vous êtes comme oui.
Est ce que est ce que je pourrais
juste jeter un œil à ma valise ?
Voir si encore il y a tout ce foutu.
Toit pour les faire ?
Pas par curiosité
Monsieur Monsieur Gaston.
Est ce qu'il
y a une rue à mon nom dans Elixir ?
Qu'est ce que tu veux
qu'il y ait une rue à ton.
Nom à Tunis ou Villeneuve que je suis,
c'est pas possible à l'horizon.
Il y a une rue qui s'appelle c'était
ici ou là.
Bon, au moins, ça veut dire Ah si là,
je suis vous, vous vous placez dis oui.
Je connais, je suis sportif,
tu faisais par le chiffre sportif.
Oui, je participais hors de la salle.
Je suis sportif. C'est un sacré hasard.
Bon, écoutez,
je vous explique la situation.
On a créé un prototype qui déplace
des objets du passé vers le futur.
Est ce que nous sommes en train
de nous traiter d'objets là, monsieur ?
Du coup ? Non.
Mais le but, c'était
que ce soient des objets.
Apparemment,
ça déplace aussi des êtres vivants.
Ah bah oui.
Et c'est un miracle que vous soyez
encore en vie d'ailleurs.
Merci.
Écoutez ça, je peux que m'en excuser.
Le problème, c'est qu'on n'a
pas fait le prototype
qui envoie les gens dans le passé.
C'est beaucoup plus dur
et on n'a pas du tout
encore commencé à travailler dessus.
Je vous donne ma parole
qu'à partir de maintenant,
je vais faire tout mon possible
pour que vous puissiez rentrer chez vous.
Vous êtes sûr ?
C'est pas juste d'inverser le fil rouge
et le sifflement.
D'ailleurs, temps,
il parle à son apprenti de Victor.
Débranche tout, on sait jamais, ça vient.
Excusez moi pour trouver une solution.
Est ce que je peux prendre des notes
pour que vous m'expliquiez vous,
qu'est ce qu'il vous arrive alors ?
Déjà,
on va parler hôtel Accommodation tout ça.
Et puis après,
peut être qu'on va en parler. Voilà,
ce sera.
Le. Moment. Il y a une grosse boule
éclairs.
C'est pouvez me décrire cette boule ?
C'est une boule de lumière qui.
Brillait de circonférence.
Au lieu d'une aiguille.
Oui, vous voyez motus
et le même genre de boule à peu près.
Je ne vois pas du tout ce que c'est. Moi,
je suis.
À 2223 et suis un.
Autre.
Alors motus, c'est un problème.
Je suis désolé.
De. La médiocrité mais d'accord.
Mais Monsieur
la madame, madame me bidonne à essayer
d'attraper cette bille qui a disparu.
D'accord. Oui.
Bien sûr rien.
D'ailleurs, je note nos ennemis.
Vous avez ressenti quoi
quand vous avez attrapé cette vie ?
C'était d'abord neutre
et ensuite c'était terrible.
Et et je n'ai plus intimes membres
et la lumière clignotait.
Et après j'étais là et on ne peut parler
de dédommagement maintenant.
Que le dédommagement.
Vous n'avez pas une assurance ?
Non, désolé.
Là, c'est plus trop le scandale.
Non, mais je vais faire en sorte
déjà de vous loger,
vous nourrir avec grand plaisir
et évidemment de plaisir.
J'ai tué ma start
up quand même en 200 ans.
Là, elle est devenue
quoi pendant que c'était la fin ?
Elle est devenue quoi.
Votre start up ?
Je ne sais pas ce que c'est, une startup.
Et Joséphine, c'est une petite entreprise
très dynamique,
créée par généralement des jeunes
un peu relou.
Comment, il y a deux ans,
j'ai oublié que c'était ça.
Normalement, je devrais être une licorne.
Vous vous rendez compte ?
Non, je ne sais pas comment je
fait.
Ah, vous ne l'avez pas.
Il vous dit Écoutez
ce que je vous propose.
Là, déjà,
je vois que ça vous a un peu remué.
Surtout vous deux. Oui, moi.
Je pense que la première chose à faire,
ça va peut être être vous remplir
l'estomac.
Oui. Ah oui !
Donc venez, monsieur,
une cellule psychologique.
Peut être aussi quand même.
Oui, on prend psychiatriques.
Mon ami
Hugo va vous préparer un bon repas.
Venez avec moi,
vous vous sortez du coup de
la salle de stockage,
vous marchez dans les couloirs qui sont
tous baignés d'une lumière bleutée.
Moi, ça me fait très bizarre parce que
l'habitude de travailler dans ces couloirs
en voiture, c'est pas bleuté.
Je reconnais qu'à moitié,
parce que déjà
la lumière n'est pas la même
et en plus tu remarque qu'il
y a vraiment beaucoup de salles
qui sont complètement laissées
à l'abandon, délabrées etc
alors que d'autres sont toujours utilisées
et bien entretenues.
Et ça fait un espèce de mix
un peu bizarre, malaisant.
Et Victor, dites moi le complexe ?
Il y a un peu
plus trop de monde qui se traînent.
Leur Victor, c'est le jeune.
Je trouve qu'il
y aurait même pas mal de monde à écouter.
Moi, quand j'étais moi, je suis concierge.
Ici, je suis concierge, concierge.
Si oui, vous étiez concierge ici ?
Oui, j'ai été.
Oui, c'est bon, on a compris.
Moi, je suis concierge.
Je peux vous dire que là, ça, c'est
pas du bon travail.
J'ai vu l'état des salles avant, on.
Fait ce qu'on peut.
Mais il était très bon,
il fait bien son travail.
C'est vrai
que. Veux pas, mais. Je peux compter sur.
Un grand plaisir de.
Là avec vous tous les deux mots.
Et voilà.
Vous arrivez
du coup dans l'espèce de petit secteur,
le lobby entre les deux secteurs.
D'habitude,
une salle de pause ou l'habitude d'autres
d'y aller tranquillement.
Ça a été complètement retravaillé.
T'as l'impression que c'est
une sorte de restaurant, alors
il y a plein de tables,
il y a une sorte de bar.
Il y a derrière le bar, du coup,
une sorte de grande cuisine
un peu ouverte, avec un grand gaillard.
Et Gaston va le voir et lui dit Hugo,
bon, je te fais.
L'histoire est très longue.
Je ne sais pas comment expliquer ça.
Est ce que tu pourrais faire
un petit repas sur ma note
pour mes quatre invités là ?
Du coup, il y aura un grand
plaisir, mais pas de souci.
Je connais Gaston.
C'est qu'est ce que c'est ce restaurant ?
Me souvenir ici, c'était transition
secteur
trois, secteur quatre
et on me devait passer.
C'est l'endroit ou on prend le métro,
quoi ? Vous vous souvenez madame ?
Je me souviens bien ce cas.
Depuis quand ?
Bon, ok, j'ai bien compris
il y a 200 ans, mais
vous avez fait un restaurant ici.
Qui pour nourrir les scientifiques,
faut bien
qu'ils mangent les pauvres déjà
qui logeaient là dedans ?
Pas de pauvres logés là dedans, ils ?
Vous venez nous du passé ?
Enfin, ça vous. Dit Gaston ?
Comment ça du passé ?
Il y a là ? Tu parles Gaston. Lagaffe, ça.
Je parle avec, il dit oui, oui,
oui, oui, on vit ici ou on ne peut pas
vraiment vivre ailleurs en même temps.
Et la ville est immense.
Qu'est ce que vous faites
dans ce laboratoire ?
La ville est immense.
Mais la ville a eu quelques problèmes.
Je suppose que vous vous êtes
pas au courant de la catastrophe.
C'est pour ça qu'on vit 2023,
vous me direz, parce que c'était.
Avant. Attendez, il y a eu un krach.
Il y avait bien. Pierre
qui s'est effondré.
Oh non.
Mes actions n'ont un battement de cils,
ça, dans l'histoire de l'humanité.
Hugo vous sert un repas
de plus normal que une sorte de ragoût
vous semble pas forcément anormal.
De la viande Hugo ou c'est un truc de
mangeurs, de granola, de restes ?
Ce plus jeune, j'ai.
Cru que je pouvais. Faire ici.
Est ce que vous voulez manger ?
Si oui, qui. Mange le repas ?
Alors moi je peux pas je.
À moi, je mange moins,
il faut que je mange.
Là, tu manges.
Je me vitamine à. Aux enfants.
Je me suis.
Moi aussi, c'est gratuit.
OK, vous avez tous le goût un peu bizarre.
Vous vous dites que vu la situation,
c'est normal que le coup soit bizarre.
En fait, que vous faites pas de plus de
soucis que ça pour l'instant.
Parce que.
Vous vous asseyez du coup
sur une des tables.
Il y a d'autres scientifiques
qui sont en train de prendre des repas,
prendre des petites pauses,
des verres d'eau, etc
Il n'y a pas mal, il y a pas mal
un peu de passage,
mais toi tu remarque que c'est quand même
beaucoup plus léger que à ton époque.
Pour toi, le complexe
Alexis a été extrêmement vivant.
Là, il y a des gens.
Mais c'est pas grave, c'est
pas comme d'hab, c'est un peu vide.
Gaston, il s'assoit avec vous,
il vous dit Ecoutez, je vous explique
en gros le problème qu'on a.
Bah oui, par pitié.
Pour faire simple, comment
et comment dire ?
Il y a une centaine d'années,
je dirai moi ce qu'on m'a expliqué
parce que je suis né après,
des particules noires se sont répandues
dans l'atmosphère du jour au lendemain
et en
quelques
jours, on était plongé dans la nuit.
C'est à dire que.
Toutes.
Les ondes lumineuses sont bloquées
et les ondes sonores sont les ondes
qui servent à communiquer également.
Donc on s'est tous retrouvés isolés,
incapables de voir la moindre chose,
incapable de s'éclairer à l'exception
d'AVC.
Et ça, on a eu beaucoup de chance.
La combustion de ce podium,
l'élément qu'on a découvert à Adixia
il y a 150 ans.
Pour une.
Ampoule comme.
Et du coup,
il vous pointe les lumières, en fait.
Et vous remarquez que les lumières,
en fait, c'est un peu bizarre.
C'est pas juste des lumières,
un peu comme des néons.
N'importe
quelle lumière que vous avez l'habitude.
Mais en fait,
ça ressemble plus à un mix entre
une lumière électrique
et une lanterne qui brûle.
C'est
comme si la combustion était très lente.
C'est très agréable à regarder
et ça crée du coup une lumière bleutée.
Je vous explique c'est
le seul moyen qu'on a de s'éclairer.
Maintenant,
c'est le seul outil qui repousse
ces particules noires
et qui nous permet d'y voir quelque chose.
Vous vous doutez bien que l'humanité,
quand elle a été incapable de
s'éclairer et de communiquer
les uns avec les autres à distance.
La catastrophe était immense
et on suppose que les victimes se comptent
en millions, voire en milliards.
Nous, on a de la chance parce que.
Puisque les gens se cogner beaucoup
entre ça.
C'est surtout pour se nourrir sans voir.
Au bout d'un moment, ça devient compliqué.
On loupe sa bouche et
c'est comme.
Ça, comme si toute.
L'humanité devenait aveugle d'un coup.
Je pense que c'est pas mal de gens
qui malheureusement ne survivrait pas
très bien.
Comment vous me faites tant ?
Un Non,
mais en fait c'est assez bizarre, mais
les plantes se sont bien adaptées
assez vite en tout cas.
Mais toujours est il qu'il
y a eu une grosse phase de crise,
le temps qu'on installe
le podium en tant que ressource vitale.
Finalement, nous,
on a eu beaucoup de chance à Horizon
et dans le complexe du Chat
parce que c'est ici
qu'elle a été inventée.
Donc c'est ici qu'elle a été
exportée en premier.
Du coup, on était pas mal déjà équipé.
On ce podium qui est une technologie qui.
Du coup
un gisement, c'est du gisement non hélium.
C'est
synthétisé en usine, mais c'est quoi ?
Et ça a été inventé à égyptiens
et du coup les premières productions
étaient à proximité.
A présent, il n'y a pas
de mines de spoliée de notre âge.
Et du coup, il y a eu des exports
ensuite à travers le monde.
Donc on suppose qu'il
y a des survivants ailleurs dans le monde.
Mais vu qu'on est dans l'incapacité
de communiquer avec qui que ce soit,
on n'en sait rien.
Donc nous, on a de la chance
d'avoir quand même pas mal de survivants
et c'est pour ça que c'est assez délabré,
pas assez pour tout maintenir.
En nos jours,
on essaie de survivre avant tout.
Et notre objectif, c'est de trouver
une solution contre ces particules noires.
Et un des axes explorés,
c'est de récupérer un bout d'atmosphère
avant que les particules noires
soient dedans.
Le problème, c'est que maintenant on va.
Surtout nous ramener chez nous.
C'est pas les. Fouilles en cours.
Là, il faut que ça change.
Joséphine à la maison bien sûr,
mais ça me parait pas
très développement économique.
Tout ça
avant, on fait ce qu'on veut.
C'est le cas malheureusement.
Alors solution ?
Du coup, est ce qu'on peut en reparler ?
Dans combien de temps ?
À peu près ce que vous pouvez
nous renvoyer chez nous.
Alors là, je n'en sais rien.
Parce que le prototype,
j'y suis depuis quand même quelques jours.
Mais on a déjà la théorie
du prototype inverse.
Par contre,
on n'a pas encore de quoi le créer.
Qu'est ce qu'il vous faut ?
Il vous faut un masque, des agitateurs.
N'hésitez pas, j'en ai plein et là,
je mangeais une poignée de.
Fois une. Poignée d'agitateurs.
Mais qui nous dit que quand vous l'aurez,
vous nous renverrai, nous et pas d'autres
gens, votre famille ?
Je peux vous dire que madame Occupe
qui va nous envoyer.
Vous voulez combien ?
Mais moi ?
Je suis un homme de science,
j'ai des valeurs.
J'ai fait une grosse erreur
qui a impliqué la vie d'êtres humains,
qui aurait pu être catastrophique.
Je regrette amèrement
et je veux réparer les choses.
Vous avez maintenant entièrement d'accord.
Donc tout va bien,
nous on discale quelque part.
Voilà,
c'est des c'est des petites vacances
un peu délabrées, c'est ça ?
Je comprends bien.
Oui, vous avez besoin d'aide, de gastro
si on peut accélérer le processus.
Là c'est bon. La perception, c'est bon.
Ah oui, je perçois
77 sur perception sur 40.
OK, une perception
58 sur
40, on va y arriver ou.
Il y en a un qui va réussir,
sinon en pire.
Donc je ressens.
Un œil de lynx.
Parce que quand tu tournes
et tu remarque un truc de fou,
il y a une horloge en fait dans la salle.
Oui, je la vois et elle t'indique.
Du coup, il est à peu près 16 h. Oui.
Je dors un peu avant 16 h.
C'est à peu près l'heure
du rendez vous que tu avais dans le passé.
Mais il y a une fenêtre à côté
et effectivement, la fenêtre,
il fait nuit dehors.
Elle fait
nuit noire.
Il ne nous a pas menti.
Vous nous avez pas menti mon bon Gaston,
de faire bien noir là et tout c'est
une fenêtre, ça c'est le.
Dehors, c'est une fenêtre.
Si c'était vrai,
c'est particulier, madame.
Oui, oui, oui, les particulier.
Vous êtes sûr que c'est pas l'hiver ?
Je fatigué là.
16 h quand même.
L'hiver,
il fait pas de la poussière ? Non.
Je ne sais pas
avec les changements d'horaires, mais.
On ne commence pas. Son heure d'hiver.
Dans un décor sonore ISO.
Oui, oui, bien sur. Non,
mais il faut au moins un petit temps
d'adaptation dans le jardin, vous savez.
Vous vous terminez votre repas
tranquillement et d'un coup clac.
Vous allez dans le nord.
Alors j'essaye de voir ce que vous avez,
des gens qui vous entendez des voix.
Vous n'y voyez plus rien du tout.
Vous entendez des voix qui
disent encore
Ça commence à faire chier tout.
Et là, ça, c'est vous.
Vous avez quand même les yeux
grand ouverts de vos yeux.
En fait, ils cherchent la moindre
étincelle de lumière.
Vous commencez à voir
des espèces de lumière un peu trouble,
un peu comme si vous avez déjà conduit
de nuit dans du brouillard.
Je suppose que les gens seront
à peu près capables de situer
que vous voyez des phares
d'une voiture au loin.
Au début, vous voyez
juste une espèce de lueur un peu bizarre.
C'est à peu près ce que vous voyez bleuté,
mais vous voyez pas ce qu'il y a.
Et au bout de quelques secondes,
un halo de lumière qui écarte
cette espèce de brouillard noire
et Gaston qui tient une torche
avec une lueur bleutée qui vous dit
désolé, une coupure de courant
pour peu que vous puissiez vous déplacer,
on va ramener,
je vous en donner une ça,
vous pouvez vous débrouiller sans moi
si jamais j'ai besoin de m'absenter
pour explique avec raison.
Et en fait,
vous vous rendez compte que du coup,
toutes les lumières que vous avez autour,
c'est d'autres gens
avec des torches
qui se déplacent dans le couloir.
La torche, c'est notre moyen de survie.
Il ne faut pas la pratiquer.
Un Gaston, il y en a une.
Il vous dit Suivez moi,
on va car je vais vous en donner.
Vous êtes OK pour. Suivre.
Ce que je peux poser une question à Gaston
en passant, oui.
De quoi c'est fabriqué ?
Le podium,
justement, c'est c'est de synthèse.
Vous vous fabriquez avec quoi ?
Alors là,
je n'ai pas la réponse en tant que MJ,
parce que je crée tout à fait
le sujet plus tard pour des épisodes.
Je pourrais te donner la réponse
plus tard.
J'ai une autre question
oui, ça, ça vaut cher ça.
Ce n'est pas.
Dire oui, parce que, en fait,
on fait de la synthétiser pour voir.
Maintenant, c'est vital, c'est à dire que
c'est au même niveau que l'eau.
Presque. Concrètement, vous voyez.
Je note la.
Nourriture,
c'est si quelqu'un a plus de podium
et il va devoir apprendre à vivre
en tant que aveugle.
Mais c'est
pas forcément donné à tout le monde,
ça reste possible,
mais c'est compliqué, ça se monnaye.
Oui, ça se monnayer
surtout avant quand on a exporter etc
maintenant il y a un peu plus des accords
parce que c'est une denrée
con, que les gens en dépendent
tellement qu'on essaie de faire en sorte
que les gens vivent quand même un minimum.
On est dans une situation de crise
absolue.
Le but c'est pas de laisser les gens
mourir dans leur coin
parce qu'ils ne peuvent plus payer.
Donc on essaye
d'être un peu sympa sur le sujet si.
Et voilà,
j'en profite juste pour jeter un œil
aux dimensions de la torche et voir
si elle rentrerait dans ma mallette
au cas ou.
Oui. D'accord, merci.
OK, au bout d'un petit moment,
vous commencez à voir qu'en fait,
ça s'accélère beaucoup autour de vous.
Vous croisez des gens qui courent vraiment
et qui ont l'air de plus en plus paniqués
et limite ça crie dans une salle au loin.
Et vous ne savez pas pourquoi
il y a des espèces d'ordres qui sont on.
Va faire ça machin.
Vite.
Dépêche toi machin truc dans le genre
si c'est sévère, là ou vous vous rendez
vous, vous rendez les garçons.
Et comment s'appelle ça ?
Qu'est ce qui se passe ?
Il y a eu un cri. Il vous dit.
Ça ? Rien du tout.
Ce que vous nous a donné ?
Un concert des Guns N Roses d'un coup.
Il y a une femme qui va. Connaître ça.
Dans votre petite boutique d'hommes de
de visibilité, qui rentre avec sa torche,
qui dit Gaston, te chercher partout,
absolument besoin de toi.
Je t'explique là
l'expérience sur laquelle on est là.
On avait absolument besoin d'électricité
pour maintenir le système.
Ça, ça peut exploser d'une minute
à l'autre si on la ré alimente.
Là, on a des gens qui sont en train
de faire tourner des dynamos,
mais on va pouvoir tenir très longtemps.
Du coup, concrètement.
Gaston est la merde.
Il commence à se dire quoi ?
Et d'un coup,
il prend un énorme coup de stress
et vous voyez qu'il perd ses moyens.
Violence ? Et la femme.
Quand tu veux dire un truc ?
Mais il est par terre. Non,
elle n'est pas par terre.
J'ai ça Gaston, mon brave.
La spirale au centre Gaston.
Faut absolument que je trouve des gens
pour aller voir
le générateur
et il va demander aux Aigles rouges
de mettre leur système de secours
en attendant.
Et elle s'en va.
Vous, le rouge,
ça me rappelle une chanson L'Aigle noir.
Est ce que vous la connaissez ?
Mon castor ?
Moi, j'ai ma montre qui bip.
Je suis en alerte critique,
pas assez cardiaque tout ça.
Il n'y a rien qui va quoi ok.
Mais déboutonné
parce que top de coton là bas, il.
S'est mis des médicaments pour se.
Défendre.
Lanvollon là j'ai rien.
Vu rouge.
Là dessus parce que je suis venu
un petit peu en précipité.
J'ai peur.
Je n'ai pas vraiment bien
bien organisé mon rendez vous, pour
une fois à une rallonge plutôt au carré.
Il y a plus là. Du coup, j'ai rien.
J'ai ma montre
qui sonne, mon cœur qui s'emballe.
Moi, j'ai
juste besoin de me caler quelque part
et qu'on reprenne tout ça
demain, si possible.
Ecoutez, je vais vous calmer
un matin ou peut être ma nuit.
Alors c'est
alors elle se met de la faire taire
parce que là, moi, ça va,
ça n'a plus du tout.
Il y a trop. De stimulations.
À Paris.
Trop de stimulations.
J'ai cru bien faire briller. Non,
non, vous.
Allez pas nous claquer dans les pattes
là pour vous.
Faut vous ressaisir.
Monsieur Madame, que je fais vraiment
ce que je peux là, je suis au maximum.
S'il vous plaît, trouvez moi un endroit
ou mettre, composez et laissez moi.
Ouais. Et Gaston.
Ayant.
La gastro, une question il n'est pas
venu donner une torche, c'est
OK, il donne nous une torche au Gaston.
Il se dépêche et tout.
Il dit je ne sais pas qui on est,
ce que je fais.
Ce que, par pur hasard,
vous accepteriez d'aller
voir ce qui se passe au générateur ?
Je vous termine, c'est
pas très loin, c'est vous.
En 1 h, vous allez faire un tour.
Je pense peut être 1 h et demie,
mais il se dit Je.
Prends le métro, Gaston, toi.
Tu as un petit tilt quand il parle
d'un générateur thermique.
Ben oui,
ben oui,
le générateur toujours thermique,
c'est moi, c'est le mien, c'est
c'est moi qui l'ai.
C'est moi qui l'ai fait et qui s'appelle.
Comment ça te rassure un peu ?
Ben oui, je me dis oui quand même, ça va.
Et puis je connais quoi ?
C'est si vous savez y aller,
alors j'essaye, allez aller.
Du coup, là, je retrouve un petit peu
mes moyens parce que
c'est quand
je suis un peu plus en confiance. Ça.
Oui, oui, je sais,
je sais comment y aller, bien sûr.
Ben du coup,
je vous amène ça vous occupez.
Tout d'abord, Gaston vous donne une torche
pour le groupe À moi, à toi.
OK, il te montre comment
on met une batterie.
C'est une espèce de petit cylindre
que tu mets comme des recharges
et ça alimente le.
Ça sert de combustible et ça alimente la.
Voilà donc tu as c'est bon.
Et il vous dit
Écoutez, il y a un raccourci,
ça va beaucoup plus vite que le chemin.
Et puis vous essayez de vous perdre
parce que
c'est un peu compliqué en ce moment.
Il vous explique,
vous dit en gros vous sortez du complexe
par derrière le secteur cinq.
Moi je vois une une.
Vous prenez le chemin pendant 20 30 mètres
jusqu'à arriver au pied du mont Ivoz,
vous longez et vous avez
une espèce d'entrée de galeries.
Et dans cette galerie,
il y a un semaine tout de suite,
il y a une sortie de la galerie
qui mène au générateur.
Ça va beaucoup plus vite que n'importe
quel chemin.
Il prend une carte qui sort.
Il vous dit Tenez la sortie, c'est là,
il vous la donne et il part en courant.
Et ça lui a stoppé.
Donc on y va vous donner.
Cette carte. Parfait.
Il est le pied du Mont.
Ivoz, c'est
ma fouille, c'était ma fouille. Oui.
C'est peut être pas le même endroit
ta fouille et je te le dire tout de suite,
ce ne sera pas le même
ordre de ta fouille.
Mais oui, le Mont Ivoz, c'est
sur un de ses flancs était d'accord.
Il pourrait pas le jeter un petit.
Je vous file un exemplaire.
Chacun de la carte qu'il vous a donné
avec la sortie qu'il a entouré
petit problème
il a oublié de vous dire ou c'est
l'entrée.
L'entrée.
C'est à dire ?
Je comprends, j'ai pas compris.
Ah oui donc on sort du roman
Le Rond rouge, on va donc se.
Rouler.
Dans le shops en régie.
Ça va vous montrer
la carte qui voit donc ?
C'est une gare, c'est
juste un rond rouge qui indique la sortie.
Sauf que eux n'ont aucune idée
de quelles galeries et l'entrée
vous les viewer,
vous verrez un peu plus d'informations,
vous verrez les mêmes informations
que moi.
OK, donc apparemment
on a une coupure de son.
Donc désolé, on est revenu.
Je vais peut être répéter pour peut être
qu'on a entendu, mais dans le doute,
je vais répéter.
Donc les joueurs, ils ont une carte
ou ils n'ont qu'un rond rouge en régie ?
Vous pouvez l'afficher tout de suite.
Du coup, ils savent ou est la sortie,
mais ils ne savent pas ou est l'entrée.
Ils vont devoir trouver leur chemin.
Vous, on va vous montrer une carte
ou vous avez toutes les informations
dont vous savez ou est l'entrée.
Vous savez qu'est
ce qu'ils vont rencontrer sur le chemin.
Vous allez pouvoir un peu vous amuser
de voir les voir
se perdre à travers ces galeries
pour vous expliquer le chat.
Ça, je suis pas sûr que vous allez voir,
mais je vais essayer de montrer
à chaque fois que je change de carte.
On va jouer avec des cartes qui indiquent
l'état d'énergie de votre.
Torche sur cinq.
Donc là, tu as une batterie neuve,
donc tu as cinq avec le temps forcément.
Et ça s'amenuise.
Si vous n'avez plus d'énergie,
c'est le noir, le fer tout noir,
donc c'est à vous de voir,
de bien réfléchir à votre torche.
C'est un peu votre,
c'est un peu votre barre de vie.
Ça s'entend.
Moi, je la, je la.
Je prends cette torche en responsabilité.
Très bien avec l'humanisme.
Voilà l'humanisme responsable.
Je me. Demande.
On m'avait demandé de faire
une petite pause en milieu d'aventure.
Je pense que ce serait
peut être un bon moment
parce que ça va peut être être un peu
long, les galeries.
Est ce que vous voulez faire la pose
maintenant
ou on fait les galeries
et on fait la pause après ?
Je retire, on fait les galeries.
On fait la galerie.
Bon, je.
Remets, c'est comme vous voulez,
mais ça ne me dérange pas.
C'est pas comme vous voulez.
Vous êtes dans la salle.
Dans le dedans. Pas de bol.
C'est plus. Tard.
On va trouver. Se fera t il pas ? Bon,
tu ? Je peux continuer.
Un peu peu auparavant,
j'ai touché le micro, désolé.
Ah oui, je suis un peu déçu, mais rien.
OK, donc vous entrez dans la galerie,
vous n'y voyez pas grand chose.
Vous voyez juste à deux ou trois mètres
devant.
En fait, c'est vraiment comme un dôme,
vous vous voyez, et après un mur noir ?
En fait.
Oui, c'est. Vraiment, c'est très spécial.
C'est pas la lumière qui se reflète
à l'infini, juste qu'ils s'amusent
comme une façade d'un coup brumeuse.
C'est le plus rien.
Donc restez près de nous, s'il vous plaît
très bien.
Vous restez, vous promenez,
vous entrez et vous.
Tombez sur une intersection.
Ça part à gauche ou à droite.
Qu'est ce que vous faites.
Mon intuition à droite
ou la droite à gauche ?
J'aurais dit la gauche aussi.
On ne se pose pas.
De question que ça va mal
ou. On vote
une démocratie, non.
Mais quatre donc donc je suis pas, je
tiens, mais le compte ça va vite bloqué.
Je tiens la torche en responsabilité,
je vous le rappelle,
donc on va aller à droite.
Ce coup ci une fois sur deux.
Vous vous décidez ensuite nous décide.
On va avoir un coup en bas à droite
je pense.
Je dirige vers la droite.
En partant vers la droite et vous tombez
sur un chemin de fer,
en fait un vieux chemin de fer.
Donc j'ai posé des rails d'une.
Ancienne mine finalement,
qui était un peu recouverte par la terre.
Et il y a un endroit ou juste
la terre se creuse et du coup,
ça révèle un peu les rails,
ça se prolonge sur quelques mètres
sous vous faire un truc avec ces rail
ou juste vous les suivez ?
Est ce que je peux lécher la terre ?
Juste tu peux lécher la terre.
Alors l'enjeu de la châtaigne ?
D'accord, elle a quelque chose terreuse.
Très bien.
Si vous voulez être
bénévole sur un chantier archéologique,
je vous prend bien volontiers.
Complètement.
Je continue avec ma torche, ok, donc
je dirige un peu, mais un peu.
Je suis les rails.
Là, les rails finissent par se relancer,
ensevelir sous la terre à nouveau
et vous tombez à nouveau
sur une intersection.
Ça continue tout droit,
ça tourne à gauche.
On a virage un peu tout droit droit.
C'est à nous de décider
qui a repris la direction avec.
Toi ou on peut aller tout droit.
Moi, je continue tout simplement.
C'est pas très vite parce que
je suis pas. Ok, il continue tout droit.
Est ce que vous le suivez
ou vous voulez l'arrêter ?
Ça ne va pas.
On va pas le perdre. Mais on va le suivre.
Et puis là, oui, je suis content.
Est ce que la chance responsable, voilà.
C'était quoi le choix
entre tout droit à gauche, à gauche ?
Merci.
On est peut être ici.
Moi, je regarde la carte,
on me dit au droite, on a voté droite,
gauche, droite, c'était gauche ou toi,
donc on n'est pas là.
On sera peut être là.
Euh, droite ou gauche ?
L'employé tout droit ? Oui.
C'est compliqué.
Donc on est
en. Marche en même temps,
mais on marche, je peux le dire en marche,
j'en ai mal au bras.
Tant qu'on marche, on regardera ca
pour passer pour passer la torche.
Ça ok.
Vous continuez tout droit et vous tombez
sur l'intersection à droite ou tout droit.
Hein ?
Je crois que je l'ai.
Un foudroiement, ça allait tout droit.
Encore une après si je me dirige tout
droit, en tout cas tout droit.
Donc il faut qu'on sorte.
Donc il faut aller de l'avant.
Voilà. C'est ça.
Le qu'il faut éviter de tourner.
Pour continuer votre chemin.
Mais vous tombez à nouveau
sur une intersection, gauche ou droite,
mais vous commencez à entendre des bruits
au loin de gens qui.
Parlent à gauche, à droite.
Ça résonne un peu.
Tu as l'impression ?
Tu as l'impression de partout,
mais tu te doute que non, pas de partout.
Et Tu stu, tu saurais pas dire de ça.
Vient tous me faire changer de perception
avec un petit malus de vin
donné par les joueurs.
N'a pas joué d'accord à 29 sur 45,
donc il a fallu que je fasse 25.
Fais moi, j'ai quatre en 900.
Le malus là. Oh non maintenant.
70, j'ai 30 sur 40,
mais avec le malus, ça passe pas.
Pourtant il très bien.
Et moi tu me demandes pas.
Tu peux, tu m'as pas dit.
J'ai 67 plus le malus sur les 40.
Du coup,
vous vous entendez ? Pas vraiment.
Qu'est ce que c'est le côté à capella
et vous.
Entendez les voix ? Mais vous savez,
vous êtes pas capable.
Je pense qu'il s'engage d'un côté et
on essaye d'appeler oui, oui, il faut la
on dans un coin.
Bah allez y Frédo, vos bras gauche porte.
Or on part à gauche, on s'avance un peu
sur la gauche que si on fait à droite.
Moi je le suis parce que j'ai pas non plus
un tir encore.
Mais vous tenez la torche ?
Tenez la torche.
On est ce qu'on peut dire Marco.
Marco.
Et en attendant.
Mais je pense pas que c'est la différence.
Les voix s'arrêtent dans.
Cette expression, ça.
S'arrête mais va s'arrêter d'un. Coup.
Dès que vous.
Parlez, est ce que je propose
qu'on essaie de chanter ? Non.
Il y a quelqu'un qui
a quand même un problème avec,
mais c'est pas grave.
Alors du coup je propose qu'on
fasse silence
parce que là c'est
un petit peu flippant quand même.
Ce que vous entendez.
Ici ce soir, arrêtez de parler,
c'est qu'ils nous ont sous.
Entendus
et ça remonte à ce qu'ils voient.
Et ils ont peur, fait un bruit chaleureux.
Et. Un mec qui c'est pas peur quoi ?
Bonjour,
qui dit bonjour ?
C'est Jésus qui vous parle ?
Le jésuite lyonnais, c'est 200 ans.
Nommé Milan, il fera de.
Son mieux par les populations.
Non mais c'est vrai que je n'aime pas
le chant.
Qui fais du bruit de Charles.
Huit.
Et cetera On essaiera Lio de la vraie svp.
Bon là j'avoue que la patience
ce monsieur chiche !
Fortiche comme marin. Et.
Je suis
le monsieur de la rue.
Chiche, fortiche de mélange.
Vous venez de la part de qui
chante en tentant une voix qui résonne.
De la part de qui ?
Oui, oh, c'est Gaston, c'est Gaston qui
s'appelle la dame qui nous été Maryline.
Non, ce n'est pas Gascon, c'est Gaston
qu'il
y a une dame qui est venue voir Gaston
et qui a dit Gaston,
il faut que tu ailles à la centrale.
Oui, mais moi me rappelle que Gaston.
Moi, je me souviens de L'Aigle rouge.
On vient voir les Aigles
rouges. Oui, il est sec, oui.
Du coup, si vous avez mal compris.
Je crois que c'est dans le rouge.
Qu'on a Gaston et allez le gérer.
Ah d'accord.
Vous vous êtes allé au Général de Gaulle.
Après, vous pouvez me parler des Aigles
rouges. Y'a pas de soucis, juste.
Un homme viennent du complexe
Elixir de la part de Gaston.
C'est des scientifiques.
Oui, oui, oui.
De ce qu'il fait.
Les balles perdues, les balles.
Quelles balles nous ont plutôt mal ?
Nous, on. A eu dans l'île.
On a eu une bille.
Mais oui, oui, oui, moi je panique,
j'éteins la torche, non merci.
Voilà, j'ai terminé.
Est ce que vous les mâchant, les balles ?
Alors vous vous tiendrez pas
une semaine en Amazonie ?
Ah oui, je n'ai
pas prévu de le faire, vous,
on arrive
pour.
Ça. Est ce qu'on peut dire, Marco ?
Moi, je propose qu'on
touche le mur sur la gauche,
on revient de l'arrière, on se cache
à l'intersection et surtout comme si
c'était pas trop avancé.
On ne touche le mur comme ça.
Ici, on est en recul
jusqu'à l'intersection.
On se touche tous les.
On ne touche pas surtout.
Ah non, on ne touche pas.
Oui, d'accord.
Touchez vous vous même ?
OK, je me touche l'épaule.
Rien. OK, je ne vous vous.
Vous mettez dans l'autre intersection.
En fait.
Non, parce que du coup, c'est face à eux.
Si on revient, on revient sur nos pas.
Quand on revient sur moi,
j'ai bien coupé le virage.
On avait tourné à gauche.
Oui, on revient en arrière.
Oui, oui, dans.
La section oui.
Et vous, vous mettez vers là ou vous êtes
pas de là ou vous venez pas, ou.
De là de là, on verra.
Oui, oui, quand même, on est pas foufou.
Et on se plaque contre le mur, non ?
Oui, c'est ça, on se concentre ça.
OK, vous vous en sortez à peu près.
Vous entendez des bruits de pas
qui se rapporte au
oui ?
J'aurais bien une suggestion.
Ce serait de retourner au rail
et la terre,
on se met sous la terre
comme ça, par terre, juste grâce.
Il faut pas bouger. J'ai ma montre
qui fait un peu de bruit.
Là, je veux dire souffre tension.
Mon cœur, quoi.
Vous bougez pas et au bout d'un moment,
les bruits de pas s'éloigner.
Vous avez aucune idée de
ce ne sont pas devant vous ou pas.
Ou ailleurs.
Vous êtes incapable de dire
parce que vous n'y voyez rien du tout
et les grottes résonnent trop haut.
Vous ne pouvez pas savoir
si vous avez croisé ou non
vous avez échappé à la mort ou non.
Je vous propose partir en catimini.
Je peux.
Et qu'est ce qu'on fait ? Rester là ?
Plutôt, on.
En part en catimini, mais on me parle.
Et puis je remets la batterie au bas.
Je pense à ceux qui sont par terre,
n'entend plus rien. Là.
Je pense qu'on peut en mettre la batterie.
Je remets la batterie à bloc.
Donc vous êtes toujours
sur cette intersection
ou vous étiez parti à gauche ?
C'était parti.
Qu'est ce qu'on fait ?
C'est
six hommes partis à droite
et qu'on les suit.
C'est peut être pas la bonne idée,
sinon ce sont nos pas
et on refait tout le chemin
et on part dans l'autre sens à gauche.
Tout.
C'était peut être une erreur stratégique
de ma part.
Depuis tout le début ou en responsabilité,
j'ai pris ma torche, je suis passé à bord,
il faut les. Suivre nous même.
La droite, c'est
la solution. Eux, ils vont quelque
peu. Viennent de quelque part.
Moi, c'était ça l'idée.
Je serais.
Arrivé sur la violence.
Sur les hommes.
Ils étaient là ou on voulait aller ?
Oui, forcément, ils sont partis ailleurs.
C'est du pour parler en catimini.
C'est ce que je vis sans les hommes,
je pense.
Oui, je suis d'accord avec madame,
évidemment, parce
qu'ils sommes partis,
il faut aller vers ou ils étaient.
Et oui, il faut aller faire.
Oui, c'était oui, ça comme un fauve.
Suivre qu'on se pour qu'on s'écoute.
Nous sommes ensemble.
Et on croit une transmission.
On peut y aller
parce qu'on est tous d'accord.
Oui, c'est comme ça.
Je connais.
La maison, on reprend.
Le chemin. Vous allez tenir. Ça ?
OK, je connais le village
parce que sinon, on est.
Sur une grande intersection.
Donc ça continue
tout droit à gauche ou à droite
en intersection.
Je pense que tout droit qu'on essayer
de tourner le moins possible,
sinon on va faire des tours de roues
tout droit.
Tu dois aller.
Se mais je vous ai pas dit
mais vous pouvez écrire sur la carte en.
Dessous. Les données c'est
plus complexe.
Parce qu'on ne sait pas.
Tout.
Donc vous continuez tout droit
et au bout d'un moment,
vous voyez que vous commencez à marcher
un peu dans l'eau.
On sera dans une eau
un peu boueuse concrètement.
Et plus vous vous avancez, plus ça
s'enfonce.
Et. Vous tombez sur une intersection.
On s'attend à gauche ou à droite,
mais ça s'enfonce.
Dans les. Deux côtés, ça s'enfonce.
Pas, tu vois juste de l'eau
tout à côté et en fait, tu sais pas.
En fait, c'est très beau, du coup,
tu ne sais pas la profondeur.
Tu vois que, à mesure que t'as avancer,
ça va commencer à monter sur tes shift.
C'est embêtant.
On a fait.
Pour l'instant, on est un peu toujours en
effet droite gauche et que du tout droit.
Donc a priori.
Et là on peut faire quoi ?
Gauche droite ?
La gauche pour. Qu'on aille à gauche.
On est là.
Si on est là
dimanche. On a fait ça.
Parce qu'on avait plutôt à droite.
J'étais le général qui.
M'a fait on le premier
pour aller à droite ou à droite,
c'est plus facile, c'est le seul.
C'est sans surprise quoi ?
C'est ce qui nous arrive
avant même que ça se passe.
Je vois gauche et.
Droite, tout droit.
Que je suis sur l'aire de mentionner
qu'on entendait là
on est du côté gauche, on serait là.
Je pense.
Alors il faudrait qu'on aille à droite,
on est bien loin.
C'est une discussion de groupe a avoir.
Moi j'ai le bras qui en gardant quand même
je pense qu'il
faut la torche depuis tout à l'heure.
Droite, gauche ou droite.
Ce que vous voulez
que je prenne le relais dans mes mains ?
Si oui.
Donc on passera à droite
et on revient par là.
On est loin. Mais
je regarde déjà sacré.
Des tours.
C'est un peu long, tordu, il faut. Bien.
Pierre-Alain ne tient plus ce qu'il
en reste normalement
et l'énergie de la torche s'amenuise
un peu.
On va passer à quatre sur cinq.
On pense avoir une piste avec madame
au cul.
Pross pense qu'on est à l'opposé de là
ou on devrait.
Oui à. Ne vraiment pas faire la. File.
Mais si, si, si.
Madame Cosse a raison.
Donc on. Est ou.
Alors je serai à l'opposé là.
Mais si tu sais.
Qu'on va pas dans le même sens.
Mais peut être donc
on serait à l'intersection gauche droite,
on serait ici.
On serait en face demi tour.
Et alors on fait un grand tour
parce que si on fait demi
tour,
on risque de croiser les autres zouaves.
Vous vous savez pas du tout,
on est vous savez pas.
Je tenais la torche, madame, je pense
en bas à droite, il faut se décider.
Sinon ils sont trois dans le noir.
Mais oui, à droite.
Dans le doute, on va à droite. OK.
Vous allez à droite,
vous tombez dans la boue.
Là, on passe.
Au final,
ça s'enfonce un peu et ça remonte.
Mais vous sortez, je sais pas.
Précise sur la droite,
vous tombez sur une intersection qui part
soit gauche, soit à droite,
et vous entendez des sortes de jappements
d'un chien qui viennent de la droite
à l'intersection.
Je cite sur le bras droit
il faut la droite. Oui.
Vous savez, vers le chien d'avant,
vers les bruits de chien.
On n'a pas le choix, c'est.
Pas les bouger. Ou alors
c'est des autres sorties
d'échappement, c'est le.
Temps des sorties ou entrées.
Si on a une bonne entrée. Oui.
Et les autres on sait pas.
Je ne sais pas ce que ça va faire.
Est ce qu'on peut qualifier les jappements
effrayés ?
Je peux difficilement. Non.
Ceci dit, si, s'il y a bien une entrée
est ici, elle n'est pas très loin.
Oui, on peut aussi aller voir.
On peut aller voir si Specter.
Si on est ou on pense qu'on est à quelques
mètres, il y a une entrée ou une sortie.
On peut regarder ce qu'il en ressort.
Oui, c'est un prospect. Une fois que.
Vous allez.
À gauche.
À gauche. À à gauche.
Est ce que rien à foutre ?
Déjà pour
donc vous avancez et vous tombez
sur une intersection gauche ou droite.
Moi je suis encore perdu mais je vous dis.
Merci mal.
Car je ne sais plus.
Mais ça ne m'étonne pas Madame.
Il faut dire on ne sait pas
et je ne sais pas, on revient en arrière.
Beaucoup de problèmes de pollution,
mais c'est comme ça, continue le chien.
On va voir le chien,
on fait ça les copains.
OK, je me.
Permet de faire demi tour
et vous allez vers là ou vous avez entendu
le bruit du chien
et vous tombez sur un vieux chien un peu.
Boueux.
Car effrayé quand il vous voyez,
il s'approche de vous tout doucement.
Vous me rappelle mon ex-mari pour.
Et alors ?
Qu'est ce qu'on en fait ?
Il a l'air effrayé. On le divorce ?
Oui, un chien,
c'est un chien, comme les chiens de 23 ans
différents.
Cocker, quelle race ?
Pardon, mais c'est important.
C'est un bâtard.
Au cœur. D'une autoroute.
Puis d'un peu ça.
Je sais pas si.
Ça va faire dans deux ans un chat.
On va pas s'arrêter son chez lui,
on a d'autres choses à faire.
Il a. L'air effrayé, mais.
Si c'est pour choper des puces.
Pour une fois
je suis totalement d'accord madame.
Alors on file, on ne parle jamais tout
doucement quand même.
On ne va pas qu'on n'est pas des monstres,
mais on va vers lui.
Dans tous les cas, oui, voilà, c'est ça.
Moi je sais pas, je me baisse
de le
plus. C'est trop gentil fredo.
C'est trop gentil.
D'écouter cette pauvre bête.
Moi il s'approche, ces. Gens.
Se blottit contre toi.
Tu remarque qu'il a un espèce de collier
un peu bizarre,
tu fais le lien assez vite.
C'est peut être dans ce collier,
il y a une sorte de compartiment
et c'est quand tu l'ouvre.
En fait c'est une recherche de spoliant.
Oh ça c'est une brave bête, mais.
Du coup il est vide.
Et en fait son.
Collier lui permettait de s'éclairer.
Du coup, il s'est retrouvé
dans son collier, c'est étant
juste perdu.
Donc c'est un chien capable d'odorat.
Du grand
non. Il est dans une galerie.
C'est compliqué.
La galère.
Aucune âme en catimini.
Je n'avais jamais regardé à l'autre jeu.
Moi, je suis David.
De ce que vous vouliez adopter.
Le chien, oui, il. Va nous suivre.
Il me comme si j'arrête de me monter
la jambe.
Est ce qu'il a pas du flair ?
Est ce qu'il peut pas ?
Apparemment non. Il est perdu donc.
Ecoutez,
si jamais il lui croise les méchants
avec leur arme,
on leur servir de bouclier dans champ.
Le chien. Pour lui donner un nom vient.
Du Gollum.
J'aimerais l'appeler Google.
Chromebook.
Google.
Non, je ne suis pas très intéressé
par le chien.
Est ce qu'il peut continuer ?
Le chien s'appellera bunga bunga
pour un vote contre zéro.
Très bien, très bien.
Vous continuez le chemin,
vous tombez sur une intersection, ça va
tout droit à gauche
ou à droite et à gauche,
le tunnel est bloqué
par une sorte de palissade en bois.
Alors je me précipite vers la palissade
et je la lèche.
À laquelle elle a un goût de chêne.
Du chêne. Le chêne, c'est bien ça ?
En 2232, il poussera encore du chêne.
Qu'est ce qu'on va faire de cette œuvre ?
Est ce qu'on peut la casser,
la palissade ?
C'est une grosse palissade. Polaire très.
Solide qui. A cassé.
Mais c'est non. Mais c'était une.
Est ce que je peux de l'enfoncer
si elle a l'air ?
Mais après, il y a d'autres directions,
donc on n'est pas obligé de par leur nom.
Le but, c'est
quand même de sortir un mouvement.
Oui, je veux dire, il ne l'aurait
pas envoyé sur une palissade.
Qu'est ce qui est renvoyé ?
C'est nous, c'est vous qui avancez.
C'est vous qui êtes devant. Moi,
je veux juste sortir que ça soit clair.
Moi, je suis assis si je.
Alors que des problèmes de solution,
j'aimerais bien me poser
l'oreille sur la palissade.
Il y a pas de bruit, pas,
mais je vivais et je tente le coup.
Je vois à travers cette idée.
Oui, d'accord,
je tombe sur le bloc et on tente.
Le coup d'épaule. C'est un jeu de forces.
Allez y.
76 sur 75.
Alors ça craque et ça ne brise pas.
J'aurais essaye.
Est ce que les autres veulent faire
un truc ?
Quelles vont être les définitions.
Et protéger mon épaule ?
Je préfère.
Alors moi, je suis et sportif,
donc je vais y aller
et je vais lui dégainer
un coup de kick flip du pied talon.
OK directement dans la palissade.
Séquence
C'est mon coup, c'est moi.
Un Un anglicisme corporel.
Ça a combien en dextérité ?
Un dex.
J'ai 40.
En fait, moi, force force.
J'ai 45. Ans.
Ce sera toujours ça, junior.
Et j'ai des ballerines aux pieds.
20 et.
Un. OK, tu fais un kick flip
et tu explose la palissade.
Et voilà, c'est comme ça qu'une. Famille.
En ayant toujours la torche dans la main,
je me suis.
Fait surface.
Bravo ma petite.
On prend des risques, merci.
Ils sont beaux ces jeunes adultes.
OK, vous avez explosé la palissade.
Vous voulez aller vers ce chemin,
je suppose ?
Voilà, on y va
le plaisir de 80 côté révolutionnaire, ok.
Du coup,
faut avancer, on est d'accord. Oui.
Vous suivez le chemin, c'est assez long
et vous tombez sur
une intersection
ou ça va à gauche ou à droite.
Toujours la même chose, toujours
la même réponse.
Voilà, si c'était long.
Si c'est lorsque
la gauche palissade.
Je suis perdue. Je me dis c'est long.
l'Odyssée longue,
c'est le plus long des barres à droite.
En même temps. C'était pas très long.
Il y aurait eu ici
si on se séparait gauche droite.
C'est pas compliqué.
Si on fait gauche droite tout le temps,
c'est pas logique, c'est toujours droite,
on tient un cap.
Oui, c'est vrai ça c'est vrai.
Pour sortir d'un labyrinthe ou d'une
situation politique compliquée,
il faut tenir le la.
C'est ça, c'est le choix privilégié.
Quand c'est particulièrement compliqué
et aussi un peu conflictuel.
On est là, on peut, on peut varier le cap.
Bon, non on a un conseil.
On en discutera plus tard.
Il faut avancer avant ça.
Le boulot.
Le problème, c'est que ça fait deux fois
qu'on va à gauche donc.
Et oui, mais on reste à gauche
si on suit la logique et si on est là.
Voilà, voilà,
on va voir ou ça va.
Nous même de gauche.
Le problème, c'est que c'est
pas comme un labyrinthe,
on ne sait pas, on va tout le temps.
Si on tient dans ce cas là,
on a juste tourner en rond.
Mais c'est vrai que si on tient toujours
d'un côté, au bout
d'un moment,
on fera tout les murs de toute la surface.
On va pouvoir faire un tour.
Il y a des solutions qu'on peut tourner.
On pourrait même le faire sans lumière.
Challenge ou je ne sais.
Si je vous suis, je vous parie
qu'on peut sortir sans lumière.
Mais bon.
Je sais pas combien.
Je serai d'avis de la droite.
Je me sens bien si on est là,
ça fait longtemps qu'on marche.
C'est le segment le plus long.
Ecoutez Monsieur Frédo.
Bon, votre.
Droite, c'est parti !
OK, c'est parti, vous partez à droite
et au bout d'un moment,
vous vous rendez compte
que la grande s'élargit
et vous commencez à nouveau
à sentir la chaleur du soleil,
même si vous ne pouvez toujours pas voir
la lumière du soleil.
C'est flippant ça quand même le soleil.
Donc vous savez que vous êtes
à l'extérieur directement.
On a l'extérieur ?
Oui, vous avez réussi à sortir.
Une station si la droite.
Elle fort.
Donc là, on est dehors.
Est ce que ça change quelque chose
quand on voit des trucs différents,
comme avoir un.
Peu d'herbe par terre ?
Ah oui. D'accord.
Et le chat il réagit comment ?
Le chien, il est avec vous ?
Il est heureux.
Il est fidèle. Pourtant, il vous. Suggère
de façon.
Surtout. Tout
à fait quoi comme chemin ?
Ouais, je me mérite.
Oui. Vous rigolez.
Alors, votre entrée,
je vous montre un peu.
C'était là, en bas.
Si vous tenez avec la sortie en haut,
c'était au milieu.
En bas. J'avais l'intuition. D'entrée.
Du coup, vous êtes allé à droite,
vous avez vu les chemins de fer.
Il allait continuer de monter ici.
Ici, vous avez croisé peut être croisé
les pieds du suspect,
vous, vous avez continué là vers l'eau.
Remonter ici un petit aller retour,
la curiosité au chien,
la barricade, c'est tout droit.
Et si c'est bien, c'est parfait.
Ce n'est pas tant tourner en rond
que ça vous.
Fait une bonne. Partie de la grotte qui.
Va bien marcher.
Croyez moi.
Vous trouverez une petite randonnée.
Ça vous avait pris pas mal de temps
quand même du.
54 sortant. Hop
voilà.
Et c'est intéressant cette.
Fois Monsieur Monsieur
Chiche ! Parti chamboulé.
Récupérer la.
Alors
je esquive un petit peu le regard
parce que
ça m'a déboîté le bras
et que je la prends, madame.
Évidemment, oui,
si vous voulez, vous souffrez de.
Je prends notre autre.
Pour info, ils ont pris encore
un peu de temps à sortir de la grotte.
Du coup, on baisse encore
le niveau d'énergie de la torche
donc on passe à trois.
Est ce que nous, on le voit, cette
information scientifique avec des petites.
Barres. Pour la. Technologie.
Ça fait un petit peu peur que ça sent bon.
Il y a plus de lumière,
une technologie. OK.
Du coup, est ce que vous voulez
qu'on fasse la pose maintenant
ou est ce qu'on y va.
Jusqu'au bout ce que vous voulez ?
Un vrai serin ?
Oui, c'est parti.
C'est parti. On y va jusqu'au bout,
c'est maintenant.
On on, on enchaîne, y'aura plus de pauses
quoi qu'il arrive.
C'est ce que.
Du coup, vous sortez des galeries
et en sortant des galeries,
vous tombez assez vite sur un grillage
qui est relié au bord de la falaise du
au niveau
du cours duquel vous venez de sortir
et qui s'étend dans une direction.
Est ce que vous voulez faire
quelque chose qui.
Va en faire une boucle.
Aménagée chez.
Nous normalement ?
Moi, je me souviens
qu'à l'époque de la construction,
parce que là,
on est pas loin des jeux thermiques.
Eh oui, oui je suppose physiquement.
Pression.
Moi, j'ai l'impression de le reconnaître
un peu.
Donc là,
je vais un petit peu sur la gauche, là
et là, il y a une espèce de box.
Si c'est comme il y a 200 ans et
que je pense qu'il y a une boîte,
non, il n'y a pas de boîte,
il y avait une boîte.
Avant, il y avait une boîte.
Voilà, je connaissais le code barres
qu'il connaît.
Extrêmement bien,
parce que c'est du fouille
dans lequel tu travailles du côté un peu
plus sur le terrain que Pierre-Alain.
En fait, tu te rends compte que
non, ce n'est pas là
qu'il se construisait le générateur. Non.
C'est vrai.
Je reconnais pas le terroriste.
Je ne reconnais pas le terrain.
Qu'est ce qu'il nous a dit ?
Je le dis ou pas, c'est toi qui choisit.
Pierre-Alain ne capte pas pour lui, c'est.
Non pour moi, c'est là.
Je vous écoutez, écoutez
là. Pour le
coup, je pense que je suis mieux placé
que vous pour le savoir.
J'ai travaillé sur ce terrain.
Le plan d'architecte que j'avais commandé
visait.
Ceci Je fortiche, j'ai passé des heures,
j'ai creusé la terre sur ce lieu là.
Si c'était l'endroit de mon chantier.
Pardonnez moi, je retrouverai de la rue
Balise du bouddhisme
qui reste très longtemps.
Y a rien de tout ça là.
Quand on peut importe,
le boîtier n'est plus là.
Oui, ce n'est pas là.
Vous vous suivez le grillage ? Du coup,
je regarde au loin.
Qu'est ce qu'il faut le boîtier ?
Tu vois pas vraiment loin ?
Vous savez joindre ses yeux ?
Tu vas pas plus bon.
D'accord pour m'aider.
J'ai échoué, je comprends bien.
Très bien.
Comme on peut loger le grillage.
Pense qu'il faut l'eau chaude.
Alors là je sens me peine
un peu de l'admettre.
Mais je me souviens du sous traitant
qui a fait ce grillage là.
C'était pas super
cher, c'est pas de l'acier non plus
si je peux.
Vous avez vous passe ?
On l'a un peu fait
pas cher le grillage à l'époque.
Tu dis bien, je le dis,
je dis c'est moi qui rend les factures,
c'est tout ce que je les ai encore.
Et on ne peut plus avoir soi
même que les trucs.
Il y a pas moyen. De
depuis je me les porte, mais en métropole,
personne ne m'a proposé de lui.
Il n'est pas très profond
s'il n'était pas très cher, le grillage,
mais il peut passer dessous.
Peut être qu'on ne va pas creuser le.
Site ou peu creuser pour. Nous.
Ceci dit, est ce qu'on
a envie de passer derrière lui ?
C'est peut être ça la vraie question.
Moi, s'il faut creuser, je peux creuser.
Peut être qu'on a pas envie de
passer derrière le grillage.
Et si on
suivait le grillage jusqu'à
trouver le boîtier, on trouve le boîtier.
Je rentre le code et on rentre.
On peut suivre le grillage
jusqu'à ce qu'on voit quelque chose.
On le suit vers la droite. Du coup.
Est ce que les codes, ça, ça change quoi ?
Enfin un. Oui,
c'est normal.
Vous longez le grillage
et vous finissez par tomber sur
le portail du grillage en fait,
qui est ouvert.
Pas besoin de code parfait
et il y a une sorte de flux.
Je connais le code, je vous tiens.
Il y a une sorte de sentier.
Toujours pas d'autre, non ?
Donc ça, on est d'accord, c'est le sentier
qui va centrale thermique, là
je suppose.
Moi je le reconnais, ça.
Ressemble et il n'est pas tranché. Oui.
C'est
toi, tu reconnais pas le lieu.
C'est sûr que t'as pas travaillé ici.
Je reconnais pas, mais bon.
C'était bon.
Après il n'y a pas trop le chemin.
Il n'y a pas 30 chemins. Vous achetez ça.
Et le chemin,
on vous progressif sur ce qui semble être
le chemin qui relie la barrière à la porte
d'entrée du générateur.
Le halo de votre torche de ce podium
finit par révéler ce qui
ce qui semble être
une grande double porte en acier.
Certainement
la porte dont vous a parlé Gaston.
Mais contrairement à ce que vous avez dit,
cette dernière est ouverte
et une odeur de fer
provient de l'intérieur.
Une odeur de fer.
Ça me rappelle mon enfance.
Est ce que vous entrez ou non ça ?
On est venu pour prendre le narrateur.
Donc après moi,
je sais pas trop comment on va la réparer.
Le narrateur, on en a l'habitude,
comme les voitures électriques,
on suit Monsieur.
Est ce qu'on peut entrer en laissant
de chien entrer devant nous au cas ou.
Le chien n'a pas envie de rentrer sans.
Le chien ?
Non, mais il rester,
il va rester à mes pieds.
Bougez pas rester dehors.
Monsieur.
Est ce qu'on
laisserait pas le chien et Pierre.
Attendre à.
L'entrée de. Guet ?
Mais on n'aura pas de lumière.
Ben oui, je ne reste pas dans le noir
Madame.
Copro, je vois bien
ce que vous essayez de surveiller quand
on a eu nos différends.
Maintenant,
je pense qu'il est temps de passer outre.
C'est vrai
qu'on pourrait coopérer un petit peu.
L'odeur de fer, ce premier méchant.
Mon papy était dans les mines, c'est
pas le genre de signal
que vous entrez.
Il y en a entre.
Notre maison
que vous pénétrer dans le hall
d'entrée du bâtiment, l'odeur de fer
se fait de plus en plus étouffante.
Puis vous finissez par tomber
sur la source de cette dernière.
Un cadavre allongé dans une flaque de sang
jonchent le sol.
Au centre de la pièce.
Dans une odeur de fer, je. Lèche le nom.
De cadavre Un.
Petit os.
Comme si. Ce réflexe.
Il est.
Ça manque de votre.
Archéologues, ce. Moment, je suppose.
Mais on dit docteur à chaque fois
oui, pour se faire appeler docteur
et du monde pour les examiner.
Comme ça, il n'y a personne.
Je suis comme un garçon. Peux ce cadavre ?
Oh, j'approche la torche pour voir
un petit peu de quoi il en retourne.
C'est une femme.
Une femme, peu de blessures.
Qu'est ce que je vois ?
Qu'est ce que j'arrive à voir ?
Tu vois qu'elle a été blessée par balle,
par blessé ?
Oui, suis blessé un peu sans avoir vu.
Mon homme a très bien
et autour, on est dans une grande salle
de pas, dans un couloir et des portes.
Ouais, qu'est ce que alors ?
En fait, sur ta gauche, quand tu rentres,
il y a une salle sur ta droite.
Donc en face de cette porte,
il y a une autre salle.
Tout au fond, c'est un peu comme
un hall d'entrée.
Tout au fond, il y a une grande double
porte qui est fermée à gauche.
Tu vois les escaliers avant cette porte
et en face des escaliers,
il y a une porte en fer fermée.
Bon, il faut prospecter.
Ou est ce qu'on passerait par les salles
proches ?
Peut être ?
Ouais.
Est ce qu'on peut quand même
jeter un dernier coup d'œil à la morte
pour savoir un peu à quoi elle ressemble ?
Est ce qu'elle aurait
un badge ? Marquerait l'homme ennemi.
Que tu veux la fouiller un peu ?
On la fouille un peu quand. Ok,
tu la fouille un peu fouiller.
Les morceaux.
Que j'ai d'endurance parce que
un peu glauque, comme pour voir ce que fut
le cadavre de Ben dans son sens, c'est
pas trop habituel.
Oui, fais mutuelle.
Pardon, c'est pas une ville de. Statte.
C'est moche, tout va bien,
ça te retourne pas trop l'estomac.
Donc tu trouves
que j'aurais une espèce de badge
ou il a marqué son nom ?
Elle s'appelle Louise Johnson,
elle s'appelait du coup.
Et tu trouves rien de spécial sur elle
pour ça ?
D'accord, est ce que je peux ?
Elle a été blessée par balle.
De combien de balle.
Dans la jambe et dans la poitrine ?
Alors je prends mon index
et je foule les plaies.
Je récupère les balles
parce que ça peut servir.
As Joséphine.
OK, c'est chanté avant de rentrer.
Du coup,
tu récupères deux balles explosées.
Je les met dans ma mallette
avec les êtres.
Vivants, les dégueulasses dégueulasses.
Vous voulez que je prenne habituel tête ?
Non, ça ira comme ça. Je vous remercie.
Je suis. Habile.
Qu'est ce qu'on fait ?
Moi, je
comme vous dit Guillaume
Prospekt commence.
Je suis pas très rassurée.
Peut être le seul reproche.
Et non le reste.
C'est de général,
mais c'est le générateur.
Après moi je sais à peu près.
Vous connaissez le blague ?
Alors vous vous souvenez.
Comment ça marche ?
Je vois comment ça marche normalement.
Tu vois, tu vois comment.
Après moi,
je suis pas non plus ingénieur, voilà.
Mais normalement,
fallait prendre un petit escalier.
Là, on m'avait montré
le jour de l'inauguration, donc
sur les plans en tout cas
petit escalier, couloir, petit escalier
qui monte
droite gauche, petit escalier qui descend.
C'est juste comme.
Ça de très pratique, non ?
Non, c'est pas ça du tout.
Vous vous souvenez plus ?
Alors donc dans ce cas
là, c'est peut être vouloir.
Choisir une pour faire. Des fléchettes.
À bombes à celle là,
c'est quand même celle là.
Sur la gauche, en direct à l'entrée.
Oui. OK.
Vous entrez et vous tombez sur un autre
cadavre qui est allé sur une table.
Sur une table.
On va, on va peut être éviter de s'il
vous plaît, un peu de tenue.
Qu'est que c'est ?
On m'a pas
toujours blessé par balle.
On appuie sur la torche.
Alors cette fois, tu as vu les plombs.
Et du coup, tu reconnais la salle.
C'est la salle du gardien, celui qui est
censé gérer l'ouverture des portes, etc.
C'est la salle du gardien.
C'est là qu'est censée gérer les portes.
Et tout. Ça,
c'est pas un très bon. Boulot.
Parce que alors peut être qu'il
y a des boutons pour ouvrir allumées.
Je ne sais pas si c'est la salle
du gardien, ma mère, qui est en courant.
Pas de courant
vu que le générateur est en rade
sur un mur.
Un plan du bâtiment
que vous avez l'air
un peu fou
et en descendant,
ils ont peut être eu des changements.
C'est vrai, c'est vrai.
Vous avez tout à fait raison.
Monsieur Petit
regarde en cherchant un plan, cherchant à.
Chercher la salle.
Vous trouvez
pas spécialement de plan dans la pièce ?
Je cherche, il a bien un bureau.
Le gardien.
Oui, je cherche dans ses tiroirs
s'il n'a pas des armes
parce que c'est un gardien,
donc il peut peut être se défendre.
Il n'a pas d'arme.
Par contre, tu vois qu'il avait un port
je sais pas comment ça s'appelle.
Aussi. Un truc pour ranger un pistolet.
Et plus le pistolet à. Lunette
qu'on lui a pris.
C'était un cow boy, peut être.
Peut être,
suppose t il. La lui même,
c'est peut être
OK. Vous pouvez le fouiller, le gardien.
Oui, oui, oui, mais là, un foyer de
fouille, oui.
Il avait en espèce de colis avec un badge,
sauf qu'il n'y a plus le bout.
Du coup,
tu comprends que c'est un colis avec
un badge au bout, sans le badge du groupe.
Mais nous, on a un badge,
on l'a récupéré le petit badge
sur Charlotte, personne ou pas.
C'était pas vraiment ça.
Ça, c'était plus une carte.
Son nom, puis il s'appelle vous vous voyez
parce que pareil.
L'espèce de petit truc
avec marquer son nom, c'est Adrian Durand.
Mais oh non, pas Adrian.
Mais du coup, il avait un badge.
Vu que c'est le gardien, c'est lui
qui peut ouvrir les salles,
mais il ne l'a plus sur le lieu. D'accord.
Alors
je prends le collier qui tient le badge.
On ne sait jamais.
Je le mets dans un colis.
Ça m'a l'air.
Gardez tout dans votre mallette,
c'est bien,
ça ressemble. À ça ressemble.
À une scène terrible, je pense.
Est ce qu'il y a eu ?
Encore une fois, beaucoup de problèmes,
très peu de solutions,
de moins de moins en moins de solution.
On y va ou on y va pas là, parce que
ça commence à être un peu shoshone.
Avons. Nous ?
Soit on fouille,
soit on essaie de s'enfoncer dans le côté.
Ils sont morts depuis longtemps,
ces gens pensaient.
Tandis que je voulais docteur.
Mais je ne suis pas docteur.
Ils étaient était marqué docteur. Oui
docteur, des objets et.
Des objets fait un effort.
Oui, ou des squelettes.
Mais là, si c'est du cadavre.
Il y a un squelette dedans.
Des jeunes.
Alors
marchons donc.
Sortez de la pièce
et vous entendez quelqu'un.
Vous appelez aller la pièce
d'en face qui n'a pas l'air bien.
Est ce que c'est une machette ?
Ils n'ont pas la même, je sais pas.
Dites moi oui.
Moi j'attends la situation là ou vous.
Vous la voyez partir
et vous y voyez plus grand chose.
Dont je connais un peu la suite.
Eglantine pour appeler à la force.
Ok et tu tombe sur un homme
qui est un peu baigné dont du sang encore
conscient dans son sang.
C'est une hécatombe.
Je vais faire des cauchemars.
Qui s'appellent à l'aide.
Et comment
va l'aide de manière claire en panique ?
Aidez moi !
Oui, de Carole, je suis passé.
Décrivez Qu'est ce qui est arrivé ?
Vous êtes pas avec ? On est d'accord.
Je crois que vous étiez avec eux.
Si vous étiez qui eux ? Là, je le prends.
C'est mon collègue, non ?
Qui a sa position latérale de sécurité.
Oui, oui, tu fais ça, mais vous voyez
bien que vous êtes docteur.
Au début.
J'ai fait du bénévolat à la Croix-Rouge.
OK, donc il dit Je ne sais pas.
Ceux qui étaient avec des câbles, je.
Sais.
Pas, ils sont arrivés,
ils ont tué tout le monde.
Des types.
Très paniqués.
Quand vous savez, ils ont été.
Vidés, extrêmement paniqués et
pas loin de tomber dans. Mon moi.
J'ai ma montre qui bip encore quelque peu.
Le souvenir, peut être.
Vous avez dit ça, la Croix-Rouge ?
Ouais, ok, je m'en charge.
OK, premiers soins.
Premiers soins, d'accord.
Et bien
là, j'ai besoin d'aide
et ce que je fais,
je jette les dés et je fais 44 sur.
C'est quoi.
Les premiers soins.
À 165 ?
C'est bon ?
Tu arrives à arrêter l'hémorragie ou.
Garder tout ça nickel ? Bravo docteur.
La PLS.
I il te remercie
mais bon il est pas bien quand même
à deux doigts de tomber dans les pommes,
il vous dit
je ne suis pas capable de marcher,
il faut absolument allumer le générateur.
La vie de milliers de personnes en dépend.
Je compte sur vous.
Il est ou ce générateur ?
Il est ou quand vous appelez,
vous êtes dedans.
Il vous donne un badge.
Son badge. Je mets sur le collier
et je me donne
OK. J'ai le badge, tu.
Peux te l'enlever,
tu le badge du générateur.
Plus le colis.
Qui vous donne ça,
il vous dit Moi,
je ne sais pas le rallumer,
mais je sais que dans les archives
techniques,
il y a des schémas qui explique
comment ça marche.
Alors ils vacillent un peu.
Je ne l'ai pas bien.
Ecoute mon brave,
tu veux et il est ou le générateur.
Incapable de marcher vraiment,
il. Ne peut pas le porter.
C'est vrai qu'on. Ne va pas s'épuiser
à le porter, même.
Si y reste. C'est un poids mort et.
Il restait dehors. Il avait peur.
Il nous faut les réponses.
Elles sont les archives.
Il est ou
le générateurs. Sont au moins un.
Le cœur du générateur,
c'est déjà la double porte.
Après les escaliers,
il va falloir rallumer le courant avant.
À chaque fois.
Je ne. Sais plus comment ça.
Mais comment on peut allumer
le générateur, ça n'a aucun sens.
Je suppose que c'est expliqué
dans les archives techniques.
Je ne suis pas technicien,
désolé. Je suis assez vieux des archives.
Il faut qu'on aille jusqu'au
plein de tout ce plan technique.
D'accord,
donc je pense qu'il faut changer les.
Objets, en déchiffrer les vieux documents.
Très utiles, pratiques.
Bref, c'est vraiment non, mais c'est vrai.
Problème.
Solution, tout ça, on est en plein dedans.
Eh bien on y va, ça va aller mon brave
mala.
On n'a pas trop le temps de dire
la Croix-Rouge,
c'est le boss sous un bureau.
Ce qui.
Serait compliqué, on le cache pour
pas que jamais, ils reviennent.
Humaniste
avant tout, voilà.
OK, donc vous allez vers les escaliers
pour descendre ?
Oui, c'est ça.
OK, donc vous retrouver au moins un.
Et là,
vous voyez un petit plan du monde en vous.
Vous savez qu'il y a. Ou il fait froid.
Quatre salles,
la salle des machines,
la salle de stockage,
des archives techniques
et la salle du transformateur électrique.
Alors
je pense qu'il
faut aller aux archives avant tout
parce que sinon, je vois pas ce qu'il
faut faire.
Mais c'est ce qu'il nous a dit de faire,
ce qu'il nous a dit de faire.
On va suivre les consignes.
Problème, solution, on y va.
Vous allez aux archives
techniques, archives
techniques, bons plans d'étagères avec.
Plein de. Dossiers.
Aussi avec des fiches etc
et vous voyez un truc ou il a marqué
en cas d'urgence ?
Est ce que ça nous concerne vraiment ?
Pourquoi pas le moment ?
C'est peut être le moment d'en discuter.
Non, c'est un. Peu tard.
On fait un petit.
Conciliabule est déterminant s'il s'agit
réellement d'une urgence, voulez vous ?
Moi, je pense qu'il est urgent
de sortir de là.
Voilà comment on fini les gens.
Faut changer le courant,
il faut faire ce qu'il faut.
Il faut y aller très bien.
Toujours d'après ce que vous a dit
la personne que vous avez sauvée à l'étage
du dessus, la vie de milliers de personnes
dépendent de ce générateur.
Après, nous, on les connaît relativement.
Peu sont. Une partie de ces. Moyens.
C'est pour ça que là,
je vous rejoins là dessus.
Soyez humaniste, mais justement
si ça arrive me plait s'il vous plaît.
Même Pierre-Alain,
c'est s'expliquera une autre fois.
J'attrape le truc, hop, tu trouves ça ?
Je trouve ça.
Parce que les autres, vous aussi,
vous voulez regarder ?
Ben oui, oui, oui ou autre.
C'est un fonctionnement
de une centrale à cycle combiné.
Ça explique comment fonctionne.
Fonctionner.
Centrale, générateurs de secours,
aspirateurs, turbine, chanteurs, noceurs.
C'est compliqué.
Mais ça me rappelle un peu, pointe. Moi.
Ça me rappelle les Shadoks.
Noyer son élixir.
On avait le même,
on avait le même motif, pas loin.
Malheureusement, vous êtes là, Fredo.
C'était pas loin de ça.
Là, vous savez jouer là parce que.
Je pense qu'il il faut qu'on aille
dans la salle du transformateur.
C'est ici, sur le transformateur,
probablement.
OK, vous suivez Frédo ?
On va jusqu'au bout du monde.
Il faut qu'on aille voir si au moins
le transformateur, il marche quoi.
Ce n'est pas notre domaine de compétence.
Nous nous remettons.
Entièrement au domaine de compétence ou.
Humaniste. Le
ou humanisme
est le développement économique.
Et vous allez dans la salle
du transformateur.
C'est très bien indiqué.
Du coup, vous vous voyez en suivant
avec votre torche sur les murs, suivi
un peu des flèches qui indiquent
vers vous, finissez par trouver la salle
ou que c'est
une salle avec beaucoup de machines.
Et sur un des murs,
il y a un grand panneau
qui a été forcé
car tu vois que le truc qui tenait
il est pété
et sur le dessus.
Sur la façade de ce panneau,
il y a une lune noire peinte.
Du luna
et en plus on est sur un truc de culture.
Le volume. C'est un peu longtemps que.
L'on peut avoir une torche.
On va passer à deux sur cinq.
Est ce que
on peut rapidement regarder dans la pièce
s'il n'y a pas une petite capsule
de ce podium qui travaille dans.
Le transformateur électrique ? Non.
Ça qu'on aurait peut être dû
regarder un petit peu.
Ouais, parce que bon, pas très bon job.
Je respecte, je regarde.
Vous avez raison, j'essaye de voir s'il
y a quelque chose de cassé, de
un bouton pas bien enclenché.
On ouvre le.
Boitier des forces, c'est quand tu l'ouvre
et en gros tu vois que c'est
un système de gros fusible.
Des gros tubes en verre.
Il y en a trois qui ont été explosés comme
si quelqu'un avait tapé latéralement.
Au plus petit que machin
semble pour qu'on me fout.
C'est dommage que c'est parce
qu'il l'a fait,
parce que là ça change un peu.
Et tu vois sur l'intérieur de la porte
qu'il y a marqué, laisse moi retrouvé.
Il y a marqué.
C'est rien.
Là. Un numéro de casier,
il y a marqué fusible de point
et un numéro 225
OK. Peut être qu'il y a
des fusibles de rechange dans ce casier.
Qu'est ce qui vous fait dire ça ?
C'est
une noire b.
Ce que vous vous souvenez
avoir vu des casiers sur la route.
Peut être c'est très bien une.
Salle de. Stockage, une salle de stockage.
Peut être qu'on peut y aller.
Peut être chercher parce que là
les fusibles si on ne change pas ce
problème.
Solution, on y va aller en route
pour aller au stockage qui.
N'est pas juste
un petit budget de perception pour.
Avoir des casiers. Tout le monde.
Donc avant de partir pour éteindre.
92. 30 32, je peux passe 170.
49 ou 46, ça dépend.
Tu vois qu'il y a coincé derrière
le panneau électrique,
une sorte de petite de petit papier plié.
Au bout, un petit papier plié.
Puis je l'ouvre, tu l'ouvre ?
Qui a marqué 1752 ?
Si, écrit Gloria sur le papier.
1750, je sais pas ce que c'est.
Une année, une année.
Un numéro technique.
C'est bien mignon.
Mais vous avez du passe. Bref,
je sais pas.
Oui, vous avez dans.
La salle de stockage.
Du coup, vous m'avez dit juste avant,
vous entrez dans la salle de stockage
gros.
Il y a plein de.
Trucs avec.
Des casiers.
En plus,
tu cherches le casier que tu as trouvé ?
Bah oui, c'était quand même moi.
Tu me l'a pas dit,
je te laisse 126 525 je crois, je pense.
Je crois que je me tourne.
Je leur ai dit OK.
Je trouve.
Le casier, il est fermé par un cadenas
à quatre chiffres.
Soit à 17 50. Sept 52.
Je sais, ça.
S'ouvre effectivement
car il y a plein de fusibles
comme tu as vu, on a des dizaines.
De problème. Solution.
Je crois que j'en prends mais j'en
prends six parce que je me dis peut être
ça peut servir ailleurs dans la salle.
Alors pourquoi tu le dis ? Oui,
je donne six fusibles avec fusible.
Ta mallette infinie. Je sais pas, c'est.
Ce. Qu'il
y a un microscope électronique à balayage,
on répète ouais,
mais être sauvé, c'est quand même.
Il y a deux et un Mac.
Ok pour vous.
Vous faites autre chose dans cette salle
de stockage avant de partir
pareil. Chercher du spoliant a du sodium.
OK, vous trouvez une recharge là ? Ouf !
Délivrance.
Valises.
Valises mais pleine, pas pleine.
Je sais pas. Il y a pas.
Longtemps,
on atteste si on est à vélo torche.
Non, non.
Jusque l'affichage de l'état.
Il est sur la.
Du coup
tu ne mets pas. De ruban dans la tête.
Changer la batterie pour voir comment
est ce qu'on peut le remettre après ?
Ben oui, je l'ai déjà fait.
Il lui. A montré.
Du coup, il s'est fait.
Moi, j'ai donné moi la torche.
Faut qu'on apprenne. À regarder bien.
Une démonstration.
Clic aurait donc lâché Noir.
Il envoie plus vite. Il fait. Là.
J'ai mis la nouvelle batterie dedans,
un coulissant de manière coulissante
et j'ai refait un petit clapet.
Voilà, il sait combien le petit truc.
Tu as
deux trois,
trois, deux, ok,
donc c'est pas bon, c'est déjà pas.
Une deuxième batterie à deux.
Donc on va logiquement
et c'est ce que je veux faire.
Si vous voulez
me donner, l'autre en est étonné.
Merci de bien vouloir pratiquer.
C'est un. Bilan.
Extrêmement précis.
OK, qu'est ce que vous faites
donc ? On a.
Je vais changer, il faut changer.
Il faut,
il faut. Retourner. C'est pour ça.
Je cherche S'il n'y a pas une barre de fer
ou un truc comme ça quelque part,
c'est vrai. Que oui.
Suis ça ? Serait ce qu'il y a.
Des objets qui jonchent le sol, jonchent
le sol ?
Est ce qu'il y a des et s'il
y a une autre, plus de noire.
On peut être rom balayer.
Ou encore
est ce qu'on peut chercher n'importe
quoi qui a l'air d'un objet contondant ?
On essaye d'ouvrir les casiers, voir
en regardant rapidement.
Un objet contondant ou alors vous trouver
plusieurs choses une corde
pour vous servir second
puis puis plein de barres.
D'outils pour. Aller prend le.
Stockage. De chacun.
Une barre, un tournevis.
Il y a de tout.
On prend un peu de.
Tout, comprend une barre, une barre.
De quoi on prend un tournevis cruciforme.
Très bien.
Si tu fais un.
Second truc. Oui.
Donnez moi, je prends,
je prends dans ma tête, je suis parti.
J'ai pris les outils dans les poches
et j'ai pris un petit marteau.
T'as pas une petite ceinture
avec des outils SQ ?
Je trouve une ceinture à outils.
Est ce que sur les.
Est ce que sur les murs,
si vous vous passez ?
Pierre-Alain la torche contre les murs,
est ce qu'il
y a des Lucas, des dessins
et ce qui est des graffitis ?
Est ce que.
Dans la salle, vous voyez rien de spécial.
D'accord, il faudrait peut être changer,
fusiller.
Choisir d'avoir été spécialement vandalisé
en étant normal.
Il faut vite.
Allez vous allez changer les fusibles.
Moi je vais. Retourner au panneau
électrique.
Bon, toi, tu sais changer de fusible.
Oui mais si tu remplaces les trois
qui ont été cassées.
Donc tu peux enlever trois fusibles
dans un forum.
Et donc
donc là.
Et sur le côté du couteau
en espèce de levier
pour réactiver l'électricité,
tu as active.
La trappe voisine, ça ne fait rien.
Oh boy dehors. Un problème ailleurs ?
En tout cas, c'est pas le transfo.
Il y a la salle des machines
qu'on a pas encore faite.
Les bois,
alors là ça peut être la turbine,
le condenseur ou le séparateur.
Ou alors la pompe qui pompe
et vient de dire juste
tous les noms qui avaient été scellés.
Je vous propose aussi d'aller voir
les générateurs de secours à pied, sinon.
Notre secours est ce qu'on peut pas ?
Mais il est mort, sinon il se serait déjà
déclenché, mais il est relié à la pompe.
On ne trouve pas de cadavres,
ils ne sont pas arrivés jusqu'ici.
C'est vrai,
il y avait des personnes à cadavres.
Oui. Il A Ils ont quand même cassé.
Ils ont fait la ligne.
Oui, enfin, la lune, c'est la lune.
Il faut aller voir la salle des machines
dans les salles des machines, donc la.
Salle des machines.
Vous entrez dans la salle des machines,
elle n'a pas non plus été vandalisée
tout à l'heure d'aller bien dedans
et vous croisez sans vous trouver ce qui a
l'air d'être un générateur en face,
un peu comme un gros groupe électrogène.
En fait. On va l'inspecter.
Tout.
De suite et en bon état, mais il faudrait
le remplir pour le lancer.
Le remplir de remplir de.
Carburant le carburant
donc a peut être un problème au niveau
de la pompe ou du séparateur
ou du condenseur corps
ou de la turbine.
Alors moi
je ne sais pas si vous aussi
ça vous fait pareil, mais ouf.
On est dans une sacrée galère
et je alors.
Est attendez parce qu'on a trouvé
le générateur et le type de rentrée.
Il avait dit que le cœur du générateur
était derrière la double porte.
Mais écoutez, c'est Saint-Denis.
C'est comme un gros groupe électrogène.
Donc c'est peut être pas le générateur.
Mais si tu pendule, on peut peut être même
fait de la double porte.
Je sais pas ce que vous en pensez.
On prend chacun une barre de fer.
On ne sait qui a fait ce groupe
électrogène ici.
On verra peut être plus tard.
Peut être
est ce qu'il
y a des tuyaux qui partent de ce groupe.
Il y a des câbles qui partent dans le sol.
T'as des bidons sur le côté.
Mais divisons dans ce bidon.
Il faut le. Rempli, il faut le remplir.
Et normalement d'après le plan,
il devrait être rempli tout seul ou.
Quoi ?
C'est une fuite de puissance,
peut être y perd un petit peu, c'est.
Pas faux, mais ce qu'on risque pas
d'exploser si on met des trucs dedans.
Vous Avez une. Autre idée que ça marche ?
En disant à Frédo M.
Comment ça marche ?
Un groupe électrogène.
Alors c'est un peu compliqué.
Je veux pas là, on n'a pas trop le temps.
Vous faites.
Un cours.
Ou ? Euh, je pense en gros un générateur.
Un groupe électrogène.
Moi je préfère expliquer le générateur,
mais là c'est plus solide.
Là c'est un groupe électrogène.
Bah grosso modo, c'est la combustion,
c'est dur, mais quelque chose a brûlé.
C'est de l'essence.
Là, on est en 2002,
ça je ne sais pas. Ce qui
entraîne
une turbine,
c'est comme la machine à vapeur.
Et puis ça tourne, quoi ?
Je ne suis pas docteur en moi,
mais c'est aussi ça
quand tu gout,
comment on fait marcher un truc
et il nous faut du carburant,
ils sont vides les bidons non ?
Qu'est ce qu'on. Attend ?
Et hop.
J'attrape
un bidon ! Oui, c'est de l'essence.
C'est l'essence de l'essence,
de 200 ans plus tard.
Le reste, c'est un fossile,
c'est plus vieux que de 100 ans.
De l'essence, du cuivre, ça. Flappy.
Incroyable, c'est. Ton essence Églantine.
Attends, je goûte.
Peut être.
Je t'ai. Dit snif. Peut être aussi.
Effectivement, oui,
je vois bien les arômes de cola au.
Six la pie, ça c'est bien raffiné.
Ça c'est la signature.
23 Vous commencez à pas vous sentir
très bien là,
ça commence à faire un peu mal
dans le ventre. J'aurais Peut être.
Corrigé des gargouillis puis.
En fait, le repas de Hugo est
ça le rêve.
Ça ou la terre, le saumon ou.
Juste frais sont multiples.
C'est vrai.
Que c'est.
Bon, mais ça commence à digérer
et ça commence à pas bien digérer.
Qu'on pourrait trouver.
Non ? OK.
Est ce qu'on peut remplir le générateur
avec ce qui va sortir de nous ?
En tout cas tous magnet parce que là c'est
en train de travailler la.
L'avenir de l'humanité.
Bla bla.
Bla. On a une salle
qui n'avait pas encore été vandalisée si
on peut s'en servir de toilettes. Du coup.
Je suis content de la solution
à ce suggestif.
Non pas longtemps lorsqu'on peut.
Se retenir deux secondes
parce que ce problème là,
je comprends, mais là
je comprends bien que je suis davantage
en maîtrise de la situation.
Donc je prends un peu plus
la torche et donc.
Est parce.
Qu'on peut mettre tout de suite
les bidons, les contenants, des bidons
dans le générateur,
on allume et on sauve le monde tout ça.
Oui je peux plus tenir, il faut y aller.
Je prends le bidon
et sous la direction de Pierre-Alain.
Active.
Je rame.
Puis ça fait.
Beaucoup de bruit et ça les lumières.
Vous pouvez éteindre torche.
C'est un succès pour.
On nous avait.
Habitués à activer un groupe électrogène.
OK C'est ce qu'on veut faire.
Qui éclaire juste le générateur.
Je prends ça comme un succès.
Personnellement,
il n'y a pas de petites victoires.
Ce n'est pas toujours la Cci,
c'est éclairer.
Nous, on n'a pas éclairé,
c'est dangereux ensuite.
Mais c'est ce qui va, c'est ce qu'il
fallait faire.
Ce que nous a dit le monsieur
mourant qu'on a, qu'on a démarré,
nous a dit de faire ça.
Et après, du coup, on peut aller voir
derrière la double porte.
Et arroser dans nos barres de.
Fer du cœur du. Général.
Vous remontez,
vous avez la double porte, il y a une.
Vous avez plus besoin
d'utiliser la torche.
Du coup, donc, l'énergie restera de là.
Tout va bien.
Il y a une espèce de lecteur
pour badge qui a le badge dessus.
Oui, j'ai le badge. Autour
et vous accédez au cœur du générateur
qui est une espèce de grande cuve
qui descend dans le sol avec de nombreux
tuyaux et un gros câble électrique
et de vous êtes un peu en hauteur.
Sur une espèce de plateforme en fer,
il y a une échelle qui descend,
mais l'échelle, elle, est coupée au milieu
et le reste de l'échelle.
Du coup, et par terre et à côté
d'un des grands tuyaux, il y a un cadavre.
On a une corde.
Églantine
Vous avez rangé la corde tout à l'heure.
La voici donc quelqu'un de souple.
A souffle.
Ça. Vous manquez de respirer,
peut être confié ça à quelqu'un d'autre.
C'est vrai que vous.
Pouvez l'attacher si vous voulez, mais
peut être quelqu'un d'autre qui descend.
On descend et.
Pourquoi on descend, descend.
C'est vrai, il faut toujours
se poser les questions, avoir
quelque chose.
On est en mode automatique.
Qu'est ce que ?
Qu'est ce qu'on voit dans cette salle ?
Tu regardes un peu autour de toi ?
Oui, en gros.
Personne sur laquelle vous êtes,
ça fait un espèce de U.
Sur les bords des murs
et aux deux extrémités, il
y a deux leviers.
Est ce que c'est pas déjà la forme ?
Il faut bien avoir.
Peut être qu'il y a un problème de pompe,
que cette échelle descende
dans la pompe, que.
Mais peut être qu'on
peut commencer par le milieu.
Il y a deux choses à faire
il faut tester les leviers
à l'écran
même voir ce cadavre pour voir si la pente
qui pourrait nous être utile,
qu'est ce qu'on met là est.
Qu'on peut se diviser, pose.
Divisée. En.
Une équipe.
Cadavre, une équipe.
Levier, levier, balle, cadavre.
Je vais le vider aussi.
Levier gauche ou. Droite ?
Droite ou gauche ?
Eglantine Est ce que vous vous sentez.
En même temps. De la corde ?
Oui, bien sûr.
Je suis d'accord.
Je Vous, je vous sécurise, je reste.
Oui, merci de vous.
Faites contrepoids. Deux et un clac.
Vous entendez un
gros comme
dans les espèces de grands tuyaux,
mais vous ne savez pas vraiment
ce qu'il s'est passé.
C'est vrai que ce n'est pas comme ça
qu'on teste.
Qu'est ce qui fait quoi généralement ?
Normalement, on fait un levier.
Là, j'explique
comment on travaille, on chute.
Sitting, c'est quand on fait un levier.
D'abord, on regarde ce qui passe
et ensuite on fait l'autre levier.
Parce que là, oui, c'est vrai,
on sait rien du tout.
En fait.
Ça fait clown, ça, ça fait clown.
C'est très bien.
Mais on ressemble à une bulle
dans un tuyau.
Après, c'est pas moi le concierge.
Eglantine, vous êtes bien. Moi,
je suis en bas.
Vous êtes en. Bas, en bas.
Quand ils ont activé les leviers.
Qu'est ce vous êtes déjà ?
Oui, moi je tire la corde.
Non, non, moi je descends pas avec.
Toi, tu vas faire changer de dextérité
et tu prends un bol
juste devant grâce au viewers.
Oh merci les joueurs,
je fais.
Pas besoin de désolé.
Sur. Ce coup là, mais vous ne. Savez.
Désolé 40. 60.
Donc tu. Tu descends en bas sans problème.
Tu vas voir le canard ou pas ?
Ou tu entends le clown.
Qu'est ce que vous voyez ? Attendez.
Je ne sais pas moi.
Non plus si je. Touche.
Approchez vous du cadavre.
Si ça vous embête pas trop.
Je m'approche du cadavre.
Je regarde le cadavre comme ça.
Est ce qu'il a un badge ?
Alors il est sur sur le ventre.
Il a une grande cape en or,
l'une noire, dessinée dans sa cape.
Et quand tu retournes, il est
complètement brûlé, armé, pas calciné.
Alors là, va falloir, je le.
Non, faudra aller chez le psy après.
Est ce qu'il possède des ?
Objets sur lui
qui pourraient nous être utiles ?
Rien de spécial.
Alors déjà je prends la cape.
Il faut qu'on passe commande et.
J'ai l'impression
que c'est revenu à la mode en 2200.
Alors tu. L'aimes ou. Tu la prends juste ?
Je la prends.
Je mets dans ma mallette
car je suis descendu avec ma mère.
Une carte avec les volumes.
C'est le petit truc.
J'avais aucun souci
pour descendre avec une mallette.
Qu'est ce que je fais d'autre ?
Je ne sais pas.
Je demande à Gloria ou Gloria oui.
Que puis je faire d'autre ?
Est ce que vous voyez autre chose au sol ?
Est ce que je vois autre chose aussi ?
Le voyage, pas un tableau électrique.
On est quoi ?
On est dans une ?
On est ou on est dans cette.
Lecture du générateur
et le mec est cramé mais.
Généralement
on a rien à y faire là dedans, non ?
Faut pas trop y rester.
De problème de turbine je pense.
C'était peut être un peu dangereux
d'actionner le levier.
Je me rappelle. De te disant.
Je pense qu'il faut que j'en ai un.
Ne respecte pas la remontée, c'est déjà
très bien.
D'accord.
Si tu regardes près de là ou il y a
le cadavre, il y a un des grands tubes
avec et en fait sur chaque tube
tu le remarque, il y a une porte.
Attention grands tubes comme nous.
Manomètre.
Il a des grands tubes
qui sont un peu opaques
et sur chaque tube, il y a une porte avec.
Une route.
Pour ouvrir la poignée et du coup, lui,
il est à côté dans ces tubes. A
donc, selon toute vraisemblance,
il a essayé d'ouvrir
et il s'est fait cramer la face.
On me fait.
Ça de ne pas ouvrir.
Ouais, alors, est ce que je peux
prendre la corde, l'attacher au volant
de manière à pouvoir être en haut
quand on tournera le truc pour l'ouvrir ?
Tu peux essayer.
De trouver une truelle.
Je peux vous donner une truelle,
une truelle ? Non, pas trop.
La physique de la chose
un peu.
Oui, vous allez pouvoir en tirer un coup,
mais pas sur la tour.
Oui, mais je fais plein de.
Je fais plein de tours
avec la corde autour du moyeu de la roue
et j'accroche trop et que par.
Friction c'est bien, mais ça.
C'est maintenant, c'est.
Le. Choc.
Et pour que je fasse.
Ok, alors je fais ça et en même temps
je remonte la corde pour. Ça.
C'est l'esprit.
Start up. C'était un problème.
En toute agilité.
Oui, c'est du du scrum centre.
Comme toute.
OK, je fais la preuve.
Du coup que c'est d'ouvrir la porte.
En fait,
tu te rends compte
qu'elle n'était pas fermée par le truc
juste, elle était juste plus poussée.
Donc dès que tu dis en fait,
elle s'ouvre plus.
Est ce qu'elle fait ?
Oui, et il ne se passe rien.
N'y a pas d'erreur.
Donc d'en haut, tu vois pas.
Attention,
parce que des fois il y a des brûlures,
on ne peut pas, il y a du feu,
on ne peut pas le voir.
J'ai appris ça il y a pas longtemps
et ça fait un peu peur.
On dirait du light.
Est ce que je peux redescendre la corde ?
Du coup, en mode tyrolienne.
Tu sais.
Descente sans plus aucun de te fais
des allers retours autant que tu veux.
Et je retourne voir à l'intérieur.
Du coup,
je sais pas si quelqu'un va me suivre.
Non, non, non, on l'a suivi et on va mieux
faire les Canaries dans la mine tout ça.
OK. Donc tu regardes dans le cube,
tu te penche un peu.
En fait, il y a une sorte de grosse
turbine arrêtée,
il y a une barre de fer qui la bloque.
Encore une
que tu nous explique peut être le truc.
Elle nourrit ce qui elle est noire.
Oui, qu'est ce que vous voyez ?
Parce que oui, on entend.
Je vous raconte
et il y a une barre de fer en travers.
Enlevez là peut être.
Oui, un claquement de protéines.
Vous vous coupez pas les mains,
faites du lasso.
Eglantine
Oui ou non, mais je peux essayer.
On apprend tout de toute façon.
Vous savez, quand on est une start up,
on fait un peu de chimie.
Vaut mieux cassez les.
Choses si vous vous jetez contre
la paroi de la turbine, est ce que ça va
pas faire tomber la barre de fer ?
Je peux y accéder à la barre de fer.
Alors je peux y. Accéder à bas.
Je l'enlève à la main.
Voilà, merci. Une simple
quand tu
as touché un peu chaude,
mais ça ne brûle pas non plus.
Je l'avais ferai plus tard.
Vous faites un truc,
vous avez vos leviers pendant qu'elle.
Peut être remontée.
On ne sait jamais.
C'est un peu fort ça.
Elle a enlevé la barre de fer.
J'ai enlevé la barre de la barre de fer.
Ce que ça a changé quelque chose,
ça a activé ça.
Ça n'a rien fait de spécial.
Mais est ce que j'ai
des leviers à activer à l'intérieur ? Non.
Je vois qu'il y avait.
Il y a une sorte de trappe fermée
sous la turbine en fait.
Alors là, je vous raconte ça. Ouais.
Et vous me dites quoi faire ?
Une traction, surtout quand tu veux pas ?
Est ce que tu fermes la porte au dessus ?
La laisse ouverte sur mon.
Je suis pas ingénieur parce que tu es là.
Alors à ce moment là, je ferme la porte.
OK, bien comme il faut.
Oui, oui, oui et je fais aussi des
bruitages et après je remonte
sans la corde, juste comme ça.
En fait,
je saute sur le mur et hop hop hop hop !
Et j'avoue.
Que. C'était fini.
Il va s'arrêter là,
il est bien mais bon ok tu remonte.
Et c'est.
Très bien.
On a toujours cette histoire de levier.
Oui et voilà.
Cette fois ci
par contre, procédure normale,
on fait un levier par un levier
comme les trois sitting.
Ça ok.
Qui en premier. Album ? Pierre-Alain.
Ce qui fait clac est active.
T'entends un clown de ton côté ?
Raisonnement que la première fois
tu commences à entendre des bruits, un peu
comme si des machines reprenaient
et tu vois qu'il
y a de la pluie, de la vapeur
qui remonte dans les tubes.
C'est bon ça, ça ?
Ah oui. Oui, c'est bon. Ça. Ça me rappelle
les années, non, mais
quelque chose qui.
Va très bien,
une dizaine d'années.
Est ce que levier ?
Peut être
est ce que je peux y activer donc.
Et c'est.
Ce que je l'active
vraiment, c'est de marcher.
De son côté.
Bah oui, il y a un levier,
mais il y a quand même deux hémisphères.
Il y a deux entrées.
Addis-Abeba Il n'y a pas de vapeur
dans tes tubes de titane.
Les tubes qui sont de ton côté, ok,
je t'en passe le levier.
Donc pareil, même bruit.
La vapeur qui remonte.
OK, c'est nickel ça.
J'ai l'impression qu'on progresse.
Ouais,
je fais un petit geste de Victor comme ça.
Pour motiver un terrain d'entente.
Un peu. Part.
Parfois, je me contente du poste de
riposte.
Est ce que Monsieur Petit,
qu'est ce qu'on a à faire ?
Parce que moi je
je comprends pas exactement.
Là, on a allumé le génie,
on a allumé le générateur,
non, on a réparé le transfo
dans le générateur.
A priori
on a remis en marche les turbines.
Donc là, tout va bien.
Si tout va bien,
le générateur devrait fonctionner.
Mais s'il y a un problème
au niveau du
condenseur séparateur ou de la pompe,
donc là il faudrait déjà qu'on s'assure
que tout va bien.
Est ce que ça marche ?
Est ce que c'est comblement ? Ça, c'est.
Jusqu'au bout ces équipes là.
Tout va remettre en marche
une usine, c'est quand même.
Voilà une partition, autre chose.
Est ce qu'il se remet en route ou.
Il y a des turbines qui tournent ?
Il y a de la vapeur qui. Sont.
Vraiment livre sur nous mêmes.
On peut sortir et voir.
Et vous retournez vers la double porte
qui vous a fait entrer.
Du coup, il s'était refermé derrière vous.
Du coup, on voit un nouveau badger.
En fait, au moment de badger,
vous voyez en haut de la double
une espèce de petite fenêtre en verre,
mais vous pouvez pas vraiment voir
à travers parce que c'est un peu en biais.
Et vous commencez à voir
des lumières rouges
se déplacer un peu aléatoirement
dans la pièce d'à côté.
Alors je distribue les barres
de fer et qui veut la cape ?
Oui, je.
Moi je joue de la comédie. De la cape.
Si quelqu'un sacrifier, c'est les vieux.
Vous serez vous ?
Ah oui, mais on pourrait se déguiser.
Ah Oui. Oui, c'est une cape.
Oui maintenant. Mais si quelqu'un. Comme.
Moi siffle un tirage,
alors du coup, comment ?
Comment ?
Oui, c'est ça. Vous pouvez planqué.
Et si jamais c'est des méchants, c'est
vous qui sortait et nous on se cache.
Est ce qu'on peut faire la courte échelle
jusqu'à
la fenêtre pour voir ce qu'il
y a derrière ?
Ou peut être un problème ?
Solution que vous savez faire.
Moi je fais la courte échelle
qui veut bien.
Agilité de
madame Églantine avec force.
Force, dextérité.
Je mets la cape.
73 sur combien de dextérité ?
40 92 sur 75 ?
Trouvé dans le clavier,
tous les objets en bois comme Borg.
Ou les lumières rouges se fige
pendant un moment.
Au moment ou elle tombe.
Et commence à avancer vers vous.
Vous avez l'impression que ça avance
vers vous ? Clairement.
Des personnes, c'est des personnes
et ça fait un petit peu peur.
Je vote, mais très rapidement.
C'est pas que je vote, je dis on se cache.
Cachez vous. Cachez vous, vous.
Risquez de vous cacher.
Vous êtes du coup sur le. Poteau en fer.
Est ce que ce serait pas
les fameux Aigles rouges ?
Ah oui, il avait l'air sympathique,
ma foi.
Enfin, en tout cas, là.
Oui, bon, on n'est pas sûr
qu'on ait pas sur eux non plus.
Mais qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
d'autre à dire,
à part peut être retourner
se cacher dans une salle de l'entrée ?
Mais là, vous êtes là,
on est donc toujours là,
on vous a dit, on était revenu.
Alors vous êtes revenu vers la double
porte.
Mais du coup, pour retourner dans le hall,
il faut la passer.
En fait, à travers cette double vente,
vous voyez des lumières dans le hall.
D'accord que vous.
Êtes toujours dans la cuve ?
Moi, je pense qu'il faut qu'on observe,
mais on ne sait pas qui sont ces gens
et comment ça revient.
Une courte échelle, énormément de morts.
Pour une
hécatombe, ou alors il y en a qui ça.
S'est bien passé.
Il y en a un qui sort avec la cape et.
Si on les effraye comme.
Ici, c'est depuis chez nous.
Bonjour, vous êtes qu'on dit pas
la bonne chose, c'est que c'est
bien de parler Monsieur Pierre,
il a la tchatche.
Oui, d'accord.
Enfin bon, vous me demandez quand même
beaucoup de choses
que je ressemblais
un minimum à la personne du cadavre.
Et on n'a même pas son nom,
on sait rien du tout.
Il y avait un Belge, il y avait Louise.
Mais pas la personne qui était
celui de la capsule.
C'est peut être pas une bonne idée
de mettre la cape tout de.
Suite, il faut la.
Parce que si c'est les ennemis, oui.
Je suis à Cape, hein. Je sais pas.
Je pense qu'il faut y aller comme ça
et tenter la discussion, discuter.
Ils ont été perdus.
Désolé, je n'ai pas envie. Oui, ça,
on les laisse parler en premier
puisqu'après tout, on est des héros
comme on vient de mettre le générateur.
Ouais, ouais, si on passe devant Cité
perdue ou il y en a remis le générateur.
Il n'y a pas moyen qu'on se cache du tout.
Aucun être compliqué pour tout le monde.
Il faut pas parler calmement.
Plomberie. C'est comme ça que ça.
S'est passé,
on s'en doute, dans la galère ce.
Soir. Les convaincre ?
Je garde quand même
une barre de fer dans la Manche comme ça.
Donc bon, je regarde dans.
Donc peut être que mes truelles les ont
sort.
Je sais pas.
Qu'on. Fait comme les rats
qui. Peuvent ouvrir la porte.
J'ai récupéré la corde avant de partir.
Parce qu'on sort un quatre.
Ou est ce que vous sortez ?
Et non.
Quand tu badges, la porte va s'ouvrir.
Oui, là, je suspends le geste.
Mais voilà, bon courage.
Peut être qu'à quatre,
on est plus intimidé aussi ?
Oui, donc
peut être on sera quatre, on va se qui.
Ou à trois.
Il y en a un qui reste derrière ce moment.
Super,
si c'est celui qui meurt, pas saute.
Je bloque,
tout le monde s'ouvre,
on est à quatre quatre.
Vous ne pas tomber sur.
Six hommes, enfin, hommes ou femmes
en face de vous, vous vous voyez pas
des gens qui sont en CAP d'enfants ?
Oh, habillés
comme des militaires, en fait.
Oh là, là, des contradictions.
Voilà exactement qui ont derrière eux
une sorte de perche avec une sorte de
torche de ce podium rouge.
C'est pas une porte de ce podium ?
Oui, ils ont dans leur dos, tête d'aigle,
ils vous braquent tous avec des fusils
que vous reconnaissez pas spécialement.
Mais ça a l'air d'être des armes à feu.
D'accord.
Et quoi nous ici en l'air ?
Alors oui, oui, lève la main.
Oui, enfin. Moi, je lève les mains.
Vous êtes dans la manche ?
Oui, c'est vrai comme ça.
On est
venu. Romain,
on vient de Elikia.
Oui, voilà, c'est.
Vous qui avez fait ça en pointant
le cadavre de la femme qui est au sol.
Ah non, non, non, nous,
on est venu remettre le courant.
Voilà.
Et vous avez laissé faire ça ? Du coup.
C'était à nous. C'est Gaston
qui nous a dit de venir.
C'était il y avait les cadavres.
On pouvait demander à.
Demander à qui ?
A Gaston, à Gaston, à Gaston d'Élixir,
mais c'est lui qui nous envoie.
Il m'a guéri.
Bien sûr qu'on a guéri une.
Oui, enfin bon, on s'en fout vous.
Et écoutez, messieurs, nous sommes là.
On a fait déjà un grand voyage,
on est un peu fatigué.
On sourit sans.
Jamais rien à foutre.
D'accord, on connaît, mais oui.
On est juste venus.
Oui, oui, bien sûr.
On est juste venu remettre le couronne.
Qui êtes vous ?
C'est vous qui venait tout rallumer là ?
Oui, oui.
On peut avoir une parole si vous voulez.
Je vous montre comment on a fait.
Regardez dans quel état
ont suffi. D'une corde et de.
Peu d'huile de coude.
D'accord.
Bon, écoutez, vous allez nous suivre.
Mettez vous au sol,
les mains derrière la tête.
Est ce que vous vous exécutez ?
Oui, on a raison des fusils.
Et si ce n'est pas fou, ok.
Il arrive dans votre dos,
il vous menotte derrière du cou,
il vous met un sac en toile sur la tête,
donc on ne voyait plus rien.
C'est glauque
et on va s'arrêter là pour aujourd'hui.
Oh là !
Et le chien, on ne sait pas.
Oh là là.
Donc le chien.
C'est bien.
Le chien va être.
C'est terrible.
Adrian Machin là durant, c'est pas comme.
Nous, on peut tuer.
Ah oui, c'est vrai qu'on est pas mort.
Et j'espère que ça vous a plu.
Tout le reste.
C'est incroyable.
Du coup, on est bien dans la merde.
C'est bon.
On a fini. La petite session
d'aujourd'hui,
on va, on va partir sur une petite
demi heure de discussion,
un peu des quelques aspects scientifiques
qu'on a pu effleurer pendant
et pendant le jeu de rôle.
Donc déjà vous, si vous avez
des trucs que vous voulez, allez voir.
Moi, j'aimerais bien que Valentine, elle,
me parle un peu plus du MEB de poche.
Le microscope électronique
à balayage poche.
Les spectateurs sont assez curieux.
Ouais, ouais, c'est
un microscope électronique à balayage.
C'est qui ? Ça va à regarder ?
Oui, c'est toi qui fait un petit.
La taille de la pièce, quoi ?
Ouais, oui, ce truc là, oui.
Mais bon, là, c'est Elikia.
C'est un monde un peu utopiste.
Tu veux qu'ils arrivent
à miniaturiser plein de trucs et.
Un, mais tu la voler en 2023 ?
Oui Moffat, on investit ici,
il y avait de la recherche.
Oui, oui, il y avait ce qu'il fait.
Il y a la même conserve.
Isolée dans un sac de jute.
Là, j'ai
remis un petit peu rapide
et il y a eu un accident.
Je crois.
Il subira
la bogue, l'avertit Si
tu veux bien.
Non contente d'être sortie
sur le fonctionnement du générateur.
Non, mais là, c'est compliqué.
Oui, moi, quand je vois un truc comme ça,
ça me déprime.
En économie, tel est le même
schéma avec écrit, entreprise,
état collectif.
Ouais, mais la différence, c'est ça
m'intéresse tu ?
Un truc fondamental dans le délire ?
Ouais.
C'est tout autant de tes cheveux.
Ouais, je suis désolé.
Il faisait chaud et tu reviens.
D'accord.
Pour les citer bien avec eux.
C'est vrai que c'est chaud,
mais c'est agréable.
C'est pas
très bien moi.
Donc du coup
si vous voulez savoir comment ça marche,
un générateur thermique
parce que je me suis renseigné vraiment.
Ben oui, oui. Un job thermique oui.
Ah ben oui. Oui,
si vous reprenez le schéma.
En gros, ça, ça chauffe de l'eau,
ça prend de l'eau chaude, l'eau chaude
qui peut fermenter, qui est du coup
sous pression très profond dans la terre.
Et du coup, en remontant, la pression
s'amenuise.
Du colo se dilate et part un peu en vapeur
et en eau chaude.
Et avec ça, du coup,
soit on l'utilise directement
pour faire tourner une turbine,
soit dans le cas
d'une centrale à cycle combiné.
Si j'ai bien compris, désolé si je le dis
un peu mieux, mais des bêtises,
on utilise la chaleur
pour faire chauffer un autre liquide
qui part plus facilement en vapeur
alors qu'il y a un taux d'ébullition
plus bas que l'eau.
Et du coup ça fait
ce fait tourner la turbine.
Donc il en faut de l'énergie comme ça.
Ça me parle.
Et il faut du pétrole pour ça. Non ?
Alors oui, le générateur de secours,
parce qu'en fait il faut une pompe
pour pomper l'eau.
Et donc en fait,
si le générateur est en rab
et que ça tourne en circuit fermé,
il faut bien un moyen de la relancer.
OK, mais après tu peux avoir
des batteries. Je veux dire.
C'était juste un.
Chauffage l'ai vu.
En fait, il faut un moyen de pouvoir
relancer le générateur en cas de panne
qui soit pas le générateur lui même
qui se développe aussi.
Donc là on a rallumé
générateur de secours.
Oui, c'est ça.
J'avais tout compris. Ça.
Et est ce qu'on a des intermittents
en France, dans en Alsace ?
Parce que là, pour des usages comme ça,
c'est on peut pas faire ça n'importe ou.
Parce qu'il y a la géo thermique de haute
énergie, basse énergie, basse énergie.
Vous pouvez en avoir pour par exemple
le faire.
Un chauffage au sol.
Donc en gros, ça va faire une surface de
quinze mètres carrés dans votre jardin
ou on va enfouir des tuyaux
à quelques mètres sous terre.
C'est des endroits ou
la croûte est plus
fine, donc c'est plus chaud
et en fait on va mettre de l'eau.
L'eau va chauffer en souterrain
et elle remonte
et ça fait un chauffage au sol.
Par contre, pour des usages comme ça,
il faut que ce soit vraiment des points,
des points chauds,
pas au sens volcanique, mais
des points ou la croûte est plus fine.
Et en France, je sais qu'il y en a
en Alsace des centrales comme ça ou là.
C'est ou
avec quelques kilomètres sous terre donc.
Mais on peut arriver à voir des trucs
très chaud comme
je sais pas s'il y en a ailleurs
qu'en Alsace.
On aura un livre de fact checking
dans la semaine prochaine ?
Oui, sur sa chaîne du.
Si si on a dit des conneries
pour compléter un peu tout.
Et du coup,
quand tu parlais des trucs avec les tuyaux
dans le jardin, c'est un truc différent.
Des pompes à chaleur ou.
C'est juste une espèce de pompe à chaleur
qui fonctionne avec de la géo thermique.
Ouais, c'est un peu ça.
Je connais pas trop pompe à chaleur,
mais c'est avec l'air.
En fait, c'est
extrait les calories de l'air tu changent.
Ce que j'ai vu. C'est juste que
ça. La température
du sol en profondeur et en moyenne.
A été.
Très frais et en arrière c'est plus chaud.
Donc tu balances de l'air, ça
génère thermique de sous l'eau.
Mais tu peux même en fait le sol.
Globalement, peu importe
ou genre à un mètre de profondeur, c'est
à peu près treize degrés toute l'année
qui va en été.
Et typiquement, il y a un moyen de qui
qui est utilisé maintenant
dans les nouvelles constructions s'appelle
un puits canadien ou un puits provençal.
En gros, on va, c'est une entrée de VMC,
mais qui au lieu
d'être juste un trou dans le mur,
ça va être un trou dans le jardin.
Le tuyau va passer à un mètre sous terre,
ce qui fait que l'air
qui va rentrer dans la maison l'été,
il aura été rafraîchi
et l'hiver, il aura été réchauffé.
J'aimerais bien ça chez moi,
c'est de choses
dans les nouvelles maisons bioclimatiques
et tout
ça n'est pas mal très utilisé.
Donc si jamais vous avez des questions,
Châteauvert Du coup, il y a des questions
sur quoi que ce soit qu'on a abordé,
ou même d'autres trucs en vrai.
N'hésitez pas, on va pouvoir y répondre.
Oui, si vous voulez.
Surtout, surtout que je n'ai pas d'œil.
Ou je reviens juste sur deux ou
trois trucs qui semblent un peu obvious,
mais on ne sait jamais,
on va quand même le dire.
Les voyages dans le temps,
ça existe pas vraiment.
Que peut être un jour on sait comment
ça ne va pas dire qu'il n'existera jamais.
Mais pour les objets,
mais pas pour les personnes.
Voilà.
Donc ça,
c'est juste pour pour les enfants,
pour les envoyer dans un monde un peu
ou ils n'auraient pas leurs connaissances
qu'ils ont dans le monde actuel.
Et du coup
que je reprendre le pouvoir sur eux, sinon
ça me pose des problèmes
pour faire de l'écriture.
Ça qu'on a tellement de connaissances
que ça va être des.
Puits de Canadiens
ou Provençaux de connaissance.
Et ça, voilà.
Et le podium, ça n'existe pas.
Peut être que
si j'ose pas, il finira par inventer le.
Podium, mais.
C'est pas le plan tout de suite.
Et du coup,
les particules noires non plus.
Vous saurez plus en détail
ce que c'est que ces particules noires
dans les épisodes qui suivent.
Et du coup, c'est inspiré d'un truc
peu réel les particules noires ou
les épisodes de poussière.
J'ai trouvé le concept
vraiment intéressant
du truc
qui fait que tu vois que tu vois pas West.
Après je comprends pas comment ça peut
marcher, mais on s'en fout pas ça.
C'est pas mon problème. Ça n'existe pas.
Heureusement, on croise les doigts.
Si un jour ça existe,
on est vraiment une grosse merde.
Je vais pas vous mentir,
mais non, ce n'est pas quelque chose
qui existe, c'est
juste quelque chose de fictif
qui a pour but de créer un monde un peu
original, original,
qui tourne autour de la science,
mais post-apocalyptique
un peu, qui change de d'habitude.
Oh, il y a le.
Jeu qui dit que
ouais.
Qui dit qu'en
plus les fluides sont riches en lithium ?
Les fluides en Alsace, non ?
Du coup, j'ai quelques questions.
C'est quoi les agitateurs de particules ?
Ah le truc dont je parlais je pense.
Soit j'ai agitateurs à trouver ce truc
qu'on utilise en chimie
en fait et un espèce de boitier en dessous
et est en B.
Cher ou n'importe quoi.
Que tu es un espèce de
comme un Tic-Tac métallique,
je crois faire un tic tac
tic tac.
Mais oui voilà, c'est aimanté
et donc ça tu le mets dans ton mécha
avec ta solution.
Et en dessous un espèce de boitier
et le boitier fait tourner ton petit tank.
Et à ce moment là ça te mélange.
Ta solution semble avoir un truc jeune,
mais un truc pareil.
Justement, je l'ai trouvé sur youtube.
Il y a des chaines qui font de la chimie,
donc je mets
filmé et je trouve ça assez intéressant
de voir justement ce qu'on peut faire.
Enfin de voir de la chimie être faite
devant devant soi parce que c'est vrai
que moi c'est un truc, je m'en souviens
d'en faire, mais c'était catastrophique.
J'en garde un souvenir un peu
bizarre et du coup de voir
quand des gens savent ce qu'ils font
et pourquoi ils le font.
Et enfin là, c'est des trucs de création
d'odeurs horribles
sur Tic-Tac qui fait ça.
Ah oui, oui
c'est intéressant.
Enfin je sais pas si,
mais juste en regarder quelques unes,
ça permet, je trouve d'avoir une idée de
ce que c'est la chips.
En tout cas,
c'était une bonne entrée en matière. Je
un coucou, Alice,
Vincent,
un Morris, il y a tout le monde ici ?
Demande Valentine.
Pourquoi on lâche des avec.
Les formats vidéo
sans les jeter qu'un.
Petit résumé,
ils iront approfondir sur la chaîne.
Au pire, c'est ça.
On peut lécher les cailloux pour,
leur goût,
parce qu'il y a certains minéraux,
qu'on a un goût salé
pour la porosité, parce que s'ils sont
pour eux une colle à la longue.
Et tu m'avais dit que le titre
que vous faisiez pareil en archéo non ?
Ouais, des fois, pour de la céramique,
on a besoin déjà d'une cassure fraîche.
Mais parfois ça arrive que casse nous même
un petit bout de céramique.
Et je sais qu'il y a des archéologues
qui parfois posent le tesson sur la langue
parce que ça va dire
s'il y a eu un engobe par un vernis.
Donc il y a un vernis,
une date plus facilement. Voilà.
En cassant, nous allons voir.
Non, dans Il suffit de la céramique,
tu veux voir la composition de la terre,
les inclusions, s'il y a du dégraissant,
si voilà quel est le c'est ça
qui t'indique d'ou vient l'argile
et donc d'ou vient la poterie ?
En tout cas elle a été faite un style.
Que j'ai vu.
Une autre petite question
elle finit ou la molette ?
Vous verrez dans le prochain,
mais vous en faites pas.
La malette sera toujours là.
Un personnage à.
Qui a un sens du sol aussi.
On en mange du sol,
c'est faux.
Alors
on ne fait jamais ça sur le sol surface
parce que c'est là ou il y a
la matière organique.
C'est dégueulasse, mais il faut bien.
Que ça soit.
Possible.
Ah oui, alors déjà
on fait ça sur n'importe quelle fin.
Voilà S'il y a une usine pétrochimique
à côté, on va pas le faire.
Mais sur certains sols, une fois
qu'on les a un peu
identifiés, on peut faire ça
pour vraiment analyser finement
les fractions.
En fait, parce qu'en sciences du sol,
on classe sable, limons
ou argile
en fonction de la taille des particules.
Il se trouve que les limons, si on le fait
glisser entre la langue et le palais,
on peut le sentir alors qu'avec les doigts
on ne peut pas le sentir.
Donc voilà, c'est tout.
Les domaines vraiment particuliers.
Ils sont en économie.
Je ne suis pas de ceux qui. Ont des euros.
On laisse. Les billes.
Il y a bien.
Des trucs, mais bon.
Je peux pas le dire.
Un truc qui me,
un truc qui me semble intéressant
et qu'on va explorer, j'imagine.
Ça va être justement l'impôt,
le statut et un peu comment
faire au niveau du spoliant,
comment il est partagé,
comment il est produit et tout ce truc là,
je pense qu'on va lui suggérer en.
Achetant du stock et d'autres
qui n'ont pas.
Les. Épisodes été un peu mis de côté
parce que forcément
vous découvrez un monde qui va
tout de suite rentrer dans la sociologie
instantanément ?
Non, mais je vois déjà
que des éléments de fin de prévision,
de pression sur des ressources,
ça c'est toujours le truc.
Mais là, c'est vrai
qu'il y avait des fusibles à changer.
Sur le live mais.
Mais sinon je vois bien
le truc ou ça peut aller.
C'est vrai
que c'est il y a plein de trucs à dire.
Justement, quand il y a des ressources
comme ça qui sont centrales
et ça a été vraiment très vite évacué.
Donc je trouvais ça intéressant.
Oui mais maintenant
c'est tellement essentiel que tout
sujet ok, donc ça marche si tu veux.
En parlant d'évacuer, il y a juste
Léa qui vit les problèmes gastriques.
Ah oui. Oui, moi j'avais c'était pas bien.
Une bonne vieille diarrhée.
Du coup, qu'est ce.
Qu'on est à terre
avec un sac sur la tête ?
Et j'en. Suis sûr, dans. L'adversité.
La serveuse vous êtes pas bien, c'est
pas au max que je pense que là
avec l'adrénaline et tout
là tu tiens quand même, tu Oui.
Ou alors ça partirait ou c'est
pire ? Ouais.
Au choix. C'est un catalyseur peut être ?
Faire un bref ce c'est
le cadet des soucis.
Voilà peut être ?
J'ai vu le site tu diras.
Mais c'est le café des sciences.
Que tu connais.
Le Café des sciences, moitié.
Le Café des sciences, une association
de vulgarisateur scientifique.
Sur de ouf.
Ouais, c'est pas moi dire
oui, bien sûr.
Il y a aussi POC Science
qui est un collectif de streamers
de science.
Ouais donc la vulgate scientifique
mainstream.
Ok. On les embrasse tous
sauf sauf
roquette.
J'ai fait ça pour Fun Facts
qui n'a rien à voir.
Du coup j'étais dans un jury de MT 180.
Ma thèse en 104 secondes et à la fin,
j'ai fini.
Chacun des jurés disait un mot
pour encourager tout le monde
et tout après qu'il soit passé.
J'ai juste dit
vous étiez tous excellents sauf un et
ils ont tous pris Superman.
C'est moi. Eux en. Rajoute.
Il y en a vraiment
qui sont partis comme ça.
Surtout,
ne mettez pas Valentine dans le temps.
C'est vraiment la leçon à retenir de
Ce n'est
plus j'avais quand
à vous.
Quoi d'autre encore ?
Vous connaissez le Café
des Sciences en oui.
Alors j'ai vu un truc m'a beaucoup forcée.
La vieille dame s'apprécie,
mais elle doit avoir des protections.
C'est pas sûr que ça soit autonome.
Elle sait comment gérer.
Ce qu'elle a dans l'histoire.
J'ai 68 ans, ce qui est quand même
pas mal du tout.
Après, je ne veux pas être. En 2223.
Nom s'accroche, vissé.
Mais je n'ai pas encore de problème
de fuite parce que j'ai fait du Pilates.
Que la prof.
M'a. Postée par.
Un maître de conférences.
À 50 ans, c'est. Vrai.
J'essaye de profiter de la. Son.
HDR, tu l'a eue l'an dernier du coup, donc
même pas.
Tu viens de finir le poste de.
Il faut que j'écrive
un article pour être publié.
Tous les ans, sinon c'est pas
la bonne catégorie qui
du coup moi je me.
Demandais pour au tout début.
On a parlé d'un papier
que tu as aidé à restaurer, etc.
Est ce que c'est vraiment quelque chose ?
Je me suis dit s'il faut,
c'est impossible.
Que possible de trouver
vraiment des papiers en état assez correct
que je puisse restaurer
malgré les intempéries etc avec le temps.
Notamment les papyrus,
mais parce que les papyrus, l'Egypte
et l'Egypte c'est un milieu sec.
Oui. Et ça conserve en fait l'archéologie.
Les vestiges qu'on retrouve sont fonction
de il y certaines zones sur terre
qui sont plus propices
à trouver de l'archéologie et notamment
dans les déserts.
C'est parfait,
c'est là ou les choses se conservent.
Il faut du chaud, du sec, ou alors
des milieux remplis de flotte
comme les tourbières.
La nature trouve bas.
Et ouais, là, il n'y a pas de balais, il
n'y a pas de pas d'air et pas d'oxygène.
Parce que.
Ça conserve les cheveux par exemple.
Ce genre de milieu.
Parce que l'humidité dans une tourbière,
ça risque pas de déloger complètement.
Là, c'est du papier.
Donc pour le papier,
oui, c'est plutôt des milieux
secs.
Ça dépend des trucs. En fait, t'as
des trucs.
Si c'est dans l'eau, ça se conserve, ça,
ça pourrit ou.
Enfin, ce que tu dis,
si c'est dans une tourbière, il y a.
Des plongeurs, mais.
Ça garde pas le papier comme ça.
Pas. Il y a des endroits
ou on met des choses.
Les tourbières, ça peut être des endroits
pour inhumer les gens.
On célèbre beaucoup de momies,
on trouve beaucoup de.
Ou alors c'est des lacs,
les lacs alpins, les lacs, pas la City.
Ce genre de chose ou tu retrouves
de l'osier, des paniers, mais.
Mais c'est aussi des époques.
C'est à dire à partir de quand on écrit
aussi l'écriture sur papier, c'est
le papyrus. C'est très récent,
c'est au moins 3000. Donc
donc finalement
après moi, je suis pas du tout
spécialiste de ces vestiges là.
Donc franchement, j'ai jamais,
jamais vu faire
de la restauration de papier.
Simplement tu vois dans les musées quoi ?
Comment ils arrivent à rendre ça ?
Tu vois bien dans les dents, dans
les tombes, que les pigments résistent
très bien.
Le bleu égyptien,
le lapis lazuli, ça résiste très bien.
Les encres, ça résiste assez bien, voilà.
Et il y a un truc est marrant,
c'est que quand on fait des fouilles.
Bon, maintenant,
beaucoup de choses sont numérisées,
mais on a quand même gardé cette tradition
de tout
texte, tout écrire sur papier
et on écrit crayon de papier
parce que le carbone, c'est ce qui résiste
le mieux au temps.
On a quand même cette logique là,
c'est de conserver l'écrit.
Et c'est pas le stylo Bic, c'est pas
le stylo plume.
C'est bien.
Et c'est agréable.
Il y a une école un peu comme ça.
Mais ouais, ouais, en fait, non,
non relevé tout au fond de papier
et nos carnets de notes
sont sur le papier.
C'est
parce que c'est le crayon papier,
ça peut se conserver pendant.
Ouais, le carbone,
c'est ce qui résiste le mieux au temps.
Maintenant, tu veux écrire tes mémoires ?
Tu peux faire un papier. Chanteur
dans mon jardin ?
Ouais.
Pendant des heures zéro tourbières.
Donc une bonne boîte en plastique
hermétique.
Qu'est ce qu'on boit ?
Je t'ai filé un document
que j'ai dit volontairement dégueulasse.
Ouais mais bon, je n'ai
pas beaucoup de capacités de graphiste,
c'est un peu moche et en vérité,
il y a un truc gris vert.
Là, il y a un texte écrit complètement.
Je sais que fait une tête
sur une session de test
avec des amis, du coup pour voir si ça va
rentrer dans les temps, etc le scénario
et ils ont réussi à déchiffrer
une bonne partie d'entre eux.
On n'a même pas essayé.
Nous on n'a pas le temps.
De toute façon tu l'as sur toi.
Tu pourras s'en après sur.
Est ce que c'est crédible
comme déformation avec le temps
ou vraiment pas du tout ?
Ça n'a aucun sens
que. Je prenne forme comme ça.
C'est des humains,
je ressemble plus Photoshop,
plutôt mal.
Non ?
Non, des évidences,
c'est pas des dégradations
que ça se passerait pas comme ça.
En fait, cette dégradation, ce serait pas
tant sur l'encre qui migre et qui coule.
Ouais.
Ce serait plus le papier qui est rongé,
qui a attaqué pour.
Avoir des trous.
Voilà des trous des fissures, des
disques.
Entre les deux, j'ai choisi
le mauvais, c'est vrai.
Mais en fait, je me pose un peu une colle
parce que je suis pas hyper.
Comme je te crois quand même,
je suppose que t'as un peu plus de.
Mais non, en fait
plus sur les peintures, tout ce qui est
peintures rupestres et tout donc
des écrits ou des peintures sur
des surfaces de la pierre et compagnie.
En fait, souvent, ça reste intact.
Et dès qu'il y a des visiteurs, des
de l'oxygène, en fait ça va pas migrer.
Mais par contre y a des ce qu'on appelle
la maladie blanche, des taches blanches
qui vont arriver sur les couleurs
et qui vont venir s'étendre, s'étendre.
C'est un espèce de grosse tache.
C'est quoi ces champignons ? C'est quoi ?
Je sais plus que c'est faux et chercheur
que je cherche,
c'est plus la maladie blanche et.
Ça c'est le truc qui arrive
dans les grottes aussi ou.
Dans les grottes, voilà.
Et à Pompéi, sur les fresques espèce de
Spa, les fresques rouges de Pompéi
qui deviennent blanchâtres.
C'est parce qu'il y a
je ne sais plus que c'est ça
un champignon ou, je pense, un champignon.
On fouille en cherchant. Et.
Essaie de déchiffrer le truc.
Ils commencent à avoir des théories.
Nous donnez pas trop d'indices,
mais extrêmement intelligents
en équipe.
Voilà tout seul un quatre
on a bien un cerveau et.
Quatre Hémisphère.
Ouais, dernier truc sur lequel je voulais
revenir, c'est la ville d'horizon
et le complexe sélection
était complètement inventé pour le
jeu de rôle.
Je crois que c'était en Occitanie là.
Est ce que si c'est pour placer, c'est
quelque. Chose qui pourrait exister
de faire une ville pilote qui. Ne.
Suivrait pas les institutions
nationales.
Des villes, des villes
un peu particulière qui sont créé
de toutes pièces dans un but précis,
il y en a beaucoup.
C'est des capitales un peu gens.
Là, c'est la capitale et du coup, c'est
un peu créé dans un but précis.
Il y a par exemple
Washington, aux
Etats-Unis, qui a été créé
un moment en mode
chaque ville était trop, comment dire
était trop connoté par machin.
Donc on s'est dit ok,
on va mettre un truc un peu au milieu.
Et puis comme ça, c'est
et donc au début, là, j'ai regardé un truc
y a pas longtemps
et justement c'était juste
la première maison qui a été construit,
une des premières maisons,
c'était à priori la Maison Blanche
et tout s'est construit.
Un jury live, The Fact
Checking, mais plein d'idées et pareil.
Je crois au Brésil aussi,
ou il y a des bras comme ça
qui ont été construits un peu sur plan
comme ça, des trucs ramenés du Sud,
je crois. Il y en a beaucoup.
En quoi
quelque chose à dire
sur les
liaisons malheureuses avec des billets ?
Je ne sais plus quel pays c'est, mais ou
ils ont fait une capitale comme ça, genre
ils ont fait des routes en mode deux fois
sept voix personne qui habite là.
C'est marrant.
Le million de morts
la capitale administrative, c'est.
Ça ça.
Mais il y a plein de
comment ça c'est avant.
Ça s'appelait comment ce pays.
Et si tu le sais, ils sont allés.
Dans Top GIR.
Peuvent.
Dormir dans un cas,
je vois Clarkson dire peut.
Après ce qui est intéressant ces villes
là, c'est que t'as plein de faim
dans le tout.
Le truc de l'urbanisme,
beaucoup d'échecs aussi, de trucs malins.
On est en train d'en voir un,
je pense en temps
réel avec le truc qui est en Libye, ça.
Lui en arabe
Samnium. Là ou c'est des trucs
qui ont déjà été testés,
des trucs sur des lignes, sur des trucs
bien particuliers, mais qui pensent
d'abord sur des concepts qui sont très
centrés sur une idée très forte.
Et en fait, c'est
pas comme ça
que les gens vivent, ce n'est pas comme ça
que les activités font un t'es
si par exemple
tu veux construire un truc tout droite,
la pression va être tellement forte
pour habiter
juste à côté
la ligne, le point le plus proche
du centre du centre.
Il est juste là.
Et puis elle est ou la centralité
dans cette ligne neuf
sur 20 sur toutes les villes comme ça,
il y a des gros problèmes de bas
de pensée d'en haut et en fait
les villes, c'est trucs
qui sont relativement organiques et
qui répondent à des pressions
un peu quasiment organiques.
Ou c'est parce qu'en fait c'est ça, c'est
une accumulation de besoin organique
puisqu'on est humains et du coup de suite
à des besoins qui sont temporels
et c'est du humanité, de toute relation
et du coup de ça,
ça ça marche pas
forcément des quadrillages
un petit peu vu de haut en bas de théorie
des besoins des humains.
Et c'est un peu tout le truc justement
avec avec la planification quoi, c'est
à quel point, à quel point est ce qu'on
peut planifier la vie des gens
et à quel point est ce que
t'as besoin en fait
que les gens vivent de la manière
dont, ils vivent.
Et puis après toi, tu essaye
d'organiser ça d'une manière
comme tu peux.
Jouer
avec toutes les tentatives d'incendie,
les quartiers autour
des gares par exemple,
qui se voulaient des quartiers d'affaires,
des quartiers ou tu vas d'un point
A à un point B le plus vite possible.
Et en fait c'est des quartiers
qui sont glauques maintenant.
Ouais, parce que parce que oui, l'humain
a besoin finalement
de centres de centre ville,
mais au niveau médiéval quoi.
Un truc c'est un déplacerons auquel
on circule de circuler avec vue
et souvent les voilà,
les artères très droites et tout va.
Après ça fonctionne quand même.
Enfin, c'est ça
qui est toujours particulier aussi.
C'est suite à des modèles,
comme on le voit dans pas mal de
villes américaines mais même européennes.
Mais c'est la séparation à ce point
là des quartiers, des trucs. Là,
ça fonctionne quand même.
Jusqu'à une certaine limite, quoi.
C'est que pour de gens,
c'est très efficace d'aller
tous les matins à un endroit,
de revenir à un endroit, de séparer les.
Activités. C'est le lieu de passage, c'est
pas des lieux de vie.
Mais peu fin à priori, peu importe.
Ça, ça dépend sur quels paramètres
tu bases le succès ou
le non succès.
Tu vois, ça peut être relativement
efficace économiquement ou sur les pas.
Ça dépend vraiment les paramètres
que tu que tu donnes.
Tu peux très bien avoir
un quartier
si tu divise les populations,
tu vas à toutes les personnes
qui vivent dans des villes dortoirs,
les personnes qui vivent dans des villes
d'affaires.
Et ça te permet de ne pas payer d'impôts
là ou tu travailles,
mais pas t'as moyen de jouer un peu
les impositions,
t'as moyen de jouer les investissements et
de vivre dans un endroit
qui protège toi ta population
et les gens comme toi et d'aller
travailler dans un autre endroit sans que
ça se touche.
Quoi ?
Il y a pas mal de choses comme ça
quand même, qu'on voit avec des
techniques de ségrégation, de ségrégation
qui ont une forme d'efficacité en fait.
Mais c'est pas forcément
ce que tu veux pour le bien commun.
Mais bon, c'est pas.
On est pas toujours à la recherche
du bien commun
et de l'optimisation de sa maison.
Moi donc.
On s'intéresse.
Le jour, on va voir justement comment
j'ai oublié les horizons.
Ils ont raison, c'est la vie et.
Alexia, mais on veut.
Justement, on va voir comment ce
quels sont les groupes sociaux
qu'on va trouver,
comment ils s'organisent,
qui est l'efficacité.
De toute la production.
Apparemment pas
obligé d'aller.
Bah si c'est oui, c'est sommes chanceux.
Vinci, Julien.
Je sais que c'est assez particulier.
Ou a été dans un cadre vraiment
très exceptionnel parce qu'une expérience
va se passer extrêmement mal qui risque
de faire exploser à minima le complexe.
Mais dans ce cas là, tu prévoit ?
Quand je veux dire. Oui, bien sûr.
Mais je me dis dans un environnement
post-apocalyptique ou les gens sont juste.
Mal organisés.
Et du coup, l'organisation
est un top genre, chacun se débrouille
un peu avec les moyens du bord.
Sous effectif. Mais c'est ça
forcément.
La moindre personne qui puisse aider.
C'est qu'il
y a des gens avec des cap comme ça.
C'est toujours ça.
Serait plus tard. Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'ils veulent.
Pas. Les superhéros n'ont pas de capes.
Attention,
c'est dangereux.
D'avoir des caps non pas. Différents.
Donc dans la pratique.
Ecoutez, vous voulez revenir encore
sur un dernier point ou on clôture
ce premier épisode ?
Les choses dans les papiers,
mais j'imagine que c'est plus rien à dire
sur les pas.
Chose intéressant le joueur pierre.
Feuille ciseaux, ça une attaque en
super.
La difficulté.
Ok. Du coup, moi
j'ai eu une petite suggestion de Régis
qui est quand même pas mal sérieux.
J'ai pas du tout pensé,
mais vu qu'on a quand même des joueurs
débutant de la table.
Est ce que c'est censé être votre
truc ?
Est ce que votre premier jeu de rôle
ou un de vos premiers jeux de rôle,
ça vous a fait plaisir ?
Genre un peu trouver la bonne.
On a pensé quoi en tout ?
C'était super, c'est très cool.
J'ai bien aimé que non.
On est en. Liberté qu'on peut avoir.
Oui, moi, j'ai saisi la liberté.
Enfin, petit à petit, je me suis amusé.
On a le droit de chialer, ok.
Et ça, même dans certains cas,
ça m'a mis heures.
Je pense à un. Moment dans des avions
et j'étais
un. Débutant qui était très fort. Ça.
Quand vous avez commencé à vous présenter
en fin de journée,
je suis débutant aussi.
J'en ai fait quinze, mais
j'ai trouvé que ça se présentait direct.
Ça rentrait dans le rôle direct.
C'était cool quoi.
Et j'espère que l'audience
qu'a pu apprécier
parcourir ces tunnels glauques.
Moi, je pensais pas que ça va
être aussi glauque.
Moi, je. Me suis vraiment plongé dans.
J'ai tout plein d'images
avec le grillage et tout.
Je les. Aime aussi.
C'est vrai que je le vois pas mal.
Je me suis dit
Tiens J'ai un sécateur, j'ai juste.
Une petite ruelle à
détruire.
Et c'est vrai que ce n'est pas l'objet
le plus.
Petit dans les supporte,
mais sur le chantier.
Est ce que t'as tous les petits,
les petits bâtons
et les petites ficelles ?
Tu les as aussi au corps au lieu.
De tirer les ficelles.
À travers une archéologie grillagée.
Quand tu fais des quadrillages, pas drôle.
Ah ouais ?
Non, non.
Non, maintenant on a un cruciforme
de toute façon.
Jamais été.
Du coup, c'est pas un truc de.
Sissi,
mais c'est des clous ou de la ficelle.
OK, on sait pas.
De quoi on a le droit de dire que.
Ça n'a pas lieu.
Quand tu me dis archéologie,
je pense quadrillages.
Ouais, mais c'est pas
avec des bouts de bois, ça en clous.
Ficelle.
Ok, moi j'en ressors grandi.
Quelqu'un qui me dit
Vous avez été top, sauf.
Mais après, on sait que c'est toi
ou c'est ciblé.
J'apprécie. Bof.
Écoutez vous chez vous ?
Merci d'avoir suivi ce premier épisode.
OK, là,
n'hésitez pas à aller chercher les réseaux
d'un peu tout le monde autour de la table.
On rappelle un peu
tout le monde sur YouTube en finale.
Vous les voir les chaînes, il y a des
dans le château pour exclamations.
Des pères de. Comptoir.
Oui, séance de comptoir Valentine
ou j'oublie le nom de ton perso
pour aller voir sur de comptoir.
Du coup pour diffamation
sont les économies.
Jupiter économie ex Arnaud ou Pierre-Alain
c'est ça ?
Et pour moi c'est pas si sauvage
ou Clotilde ou Gloria.
Et moi c'est frérot ou ou Frédéric
ou Gautier ou je spoil en plus.
Non non, il y en a chacun cinq six
parce que j'ai pris les orthographes.
Vous pouvez faire des fautes.
Ça devrait plaisir.
Vous allez vous me débrouiller.
Sans avec accent, sans accent.
Il n'y a pas de fautes,
il n'y a que des opportunités.
Et pour Guillaume, c'est MJ the Willow.
Oui bon, moi.
Je crois que oui, oui MJ ça suffit.
Mais MJ ce bon,
il n'y a pas de fautes à faire là
c'est la lettre, même la lettre. Je dis
non, moi je ne fais pas de science
désormais en jeu,
je joue un peu de jeu vidéo sur Twitch.
Non mais oui.
Bon, si vous voulez passer je et venir
poser des questions sur le jeu de rôle,
c'est avec grand plaisir
que je répondrais.
Balancer tout le. Secret.
Je ne vais pas vous dire en ont peu
parler.
Si vous avez des idées à me donner,
n'hésitez pas parce que ça peut être cool.
Mais vraiment, vous avez des bonnes idées
que vous me donnez.
Je vous dira peut être pour replanter etc
mais voilà.
Voilà.
Donc n'hésitez pas
à passer par les réseaux sociaux
d'un peu tout le monde.
On remercie encore une fois
le CNC de nous aider à financer le projet
Le Quai des savoirs de nous prêter
le studio qui est quand même vraiment
très très stylé.
Les équipes du.
Quai nous filer un coup de main,
notamment.
Mariette Barrière de la Barre
qui en régie, qui fait des.
Petits gestes de victoire.
Voilà.
Alors merci
Paulo.
La chaîne, il y aura un live de fact
checking.
Est ce que la Maison Blanche est bien
la première maison construite
à Washington quand a été inventé le pierre
feuille, papier, ciseaux ?
Toutes ces,
on les aurait dans un prochain live, tu.
Sais, vers quand tu vas le faire.
Cela sera mon prochain à peu près.
Déjà en milieu de semaine,
début de semaine.
Allez, je dirais
peut être le week end prochain.
OK, donc dans une semaine.
Voilà, dans une semaine,
vous aurez la vedette sur YouTube.
Dans sept jours tout à pied vendredi.
Vendredi soir, la vidéo sur YouTube
et sur les plateformes de podcasts,
podcasts, YouTube.
Elle sera sous titrée.
Et puis voilà.
Merci à notre homme. Je vous dis merci.
Merci les joueurs.
Évidemment, et surtout notre héros.
Merci la régie.
Eh oui, parle de la vie sans eux.
Vous, vous n'avez pas vu grand chose
ce soir dans les grands shows, on.
Serait dans le noir.
Une partition centrale et un peu plus.
Je pense. Live sans la régie. Merci.
Merci Nico, je sais pas.
Vous voulez qu'on
dise ou non l'invité de ce jour ?
C'est balancé.
Voilà donc comme Gauthier l'a dit,
le Ripley.
Bientôt sur YouTube ?
Sur la plateforme de podcast,
n'hésitez pas à suivre aussi.
Les comptes de World of Signs.
C'est donc Twit Tik Tok, Instant Tweeter
parce que là,
vous allez avoir plein de clips jusqu'au
jusqu'à la prochaine émission.
En fait,
vous allez voir des clips des Bousman,
des résumés, des tweets,
si possible en photo.
J'aime mieux que juste posée sur la table.
Des petits trucs
comme ça. Donc n'hésitez pas.
À nous faire.
Du coup, on se revoit dans deux semaines.
C'est ça ? C'est ça.
Ça va être sérieux.
Tu n'as pas mis de commande ?
Gloire à Thomas, dix ans de commande.
Je pense qu'on va être beaucoup de famille
comme on va
en mode bam directement.
On va réfléchir à un personnage davantage.
On va leur donner un peu de profondeur.
La texture, c'était l'occasion de
les appréhender, d'apprendre à connaître.
C'est ça pas chichis.
Ils vous plaisent dont perso.
Je ne parle pas de coach
s'il.
Vous plaît. Si je. Ne faisais. Jeter.
Par destination
les commandes, elles viendront
titiller.
Voilà, merci. Merci.
Merci beaucoup. Ça.
Oui, merci.
On se retrouve dans deux semaines,
du coup il va passer une bonne soirée.
Bon week end.
La prochaine fois
bientôt Spadium sublime les.